I have
been told to put the microphone right
here. So, I apologize about the P's.
It's the sound. Is it okay? Okay.
All right. I'm to turn it over to
Principal Barrett to launch it.
Good morning, everybody. Uh, thank you
so much for being here. Today is one of
my favorite days every year. Book
character parade is always like one of
the greatest events. Um, some of us this
morning were talking about past book
character parades and my first book
character parade here at Becker was in
uh when we had the gar or the Onion
Creek floods. I was dressed as Curious
George. My kids, my graders were here at
PE and I was in the other building in
the annex. And so as we all sheltered in
place in the hallways in the main
building, I ended up with kindergarten
um crying for hours. And so I found all
the books that I could pull together to
read to the kids during that. And so
that just kind of is a story about, you
know, the history we've had here in this
building. Um but I was really grateful
to see all of you this morning. It was
an amazing turnout. So thank you so much
and thank you for your support of our
campus and our community. It really
means a lot. over the last weeks. We
have definitely been feeling the Becker
love from our community. So, thank you.
Um before we get started, just a couple
of housekeeping things. When we get to
doing questions, uh we would like our
our community to come and stand at the
cones for the questions. Um and as
Victoria said, we need to have the mic
here close so that it works well. So,
thank you. I'm going to go ahead and
pass it over to Victoria.
>> Good morning, buddy. My name is Victoria
O'Neal and I'm the executive director of
uh campus and family engagement. Uh
happy to be here with you today uh along
with Superintendent Sigura and uh the
team of experts that we have here to
help address your questions.
>> Um so first we will review the agenda.
Um thank you to Principal Barrett for
hosting us and uh providing a warm
welcome. Um, we will review the meeting
norms and purpose and then provide a
very brief overview of your campus
specific proposed changes. We'll do some
introductions of the district staff who
are here. Uh, and then we have slides
that respond directly to comments that
were submitted on the comment cards and
we can talk about next steps. Of course,
um we will also take questions from the
room. So, we can intersperse the
questions from the comment card with um
questions and comments from the room. Uh
and um we can also be responsive. So, if
a question on a comment card pops up and
everyone's like, "Yeah, we got that."
Then we can skip it and move on. Right?
So, we're here to have a dialogue. So
for our norms, um we definitely
acknowledge that the challenges we have
here today and um the coming together of
ideas and solutions make our district
stronger and so we are looking to build
the future together. Um we would like to
honor the time that we have here today
and so we do ask each speaker to hold to
one minute uh and
um
to allow as many voices as possible and
then also um one opportunity for um one
question. Right? So if you have multiple
questions that are unrelated um we ask
that you pass the mic and then we can
we'll try to come back to you for your
second question. Um and when we are
speaking speaking to have speak to each
other and um make sure that we hold a
community of respect we ask please allow
folks to one speaker at a time um and to
avoid interruptions.
The process here today was uh shared by
myself with the agenda and principal
Barrett and uh this meeting format
allows us to uh have the widest who are
here and um to respect the time and
space that we have and we may disagree
on the ideas uh but we all have a
positive intent for the future for all
of us and that is our shared goal. Uh in
terms of honoring space and voice um we
do want to allow as many people uh to
participate as possible. So please be
mindful of um how many people have
spoken and how many might like the
opportunity to do so. And we are here to
focus on ideas, solutions, and
understanding. Um, and to embrace
transparency and empathy. Difficult
questions are difficult. Uh, but we all
can, um, work together and hold a spirit
of compassion and respect here in the
room with us today.
Um, we also have the norms in Spanish.
Uh all of the slides are bilingual and
we have our interpretation team on the
side of the room here. So if there is
anybody who would like um simultaneous
interpretation into Spanish, we have the
um team and the equipment to do so.
Okay.
Um, so again, our purpose is to respond
to the questions submitted via the
comment card. Uh, every single of the
almost 7,000 comment card uh that were
submitted were read and digested. Um
much of that content will be reflected
in the um revised document that will be
released today. And um there were
valuable questions that were raised um
things that were brought up and so we
want to provide um responses to
questions that were submitted directly
from the Becker community. Uh we want to
continue to grow our understanding of
the proposed ch shared understanding of
the proposed changes and to gain
insights that will continue um our
refinement process. Um we aren't done
and uh we continue to listen and so at
this point I will turn it over to
superintendent.
>> All right. Um thank you all for being
here this morning. Uh
>> you know this is this is what you want
in Austin IC. You want families to show
up. to advocate. We have incredible
schools and I just want to just express
my sincere appreciation for showing up
um and supporting this incredible
school. Before we get going, I do want
to acknowledge we have a couple trustees
here. Uh we have our board president,
President Lyn Boswell, who I know.
[applause]
We also have trustee Kaufman and former
principal.
[applause and cheering]
Uh, I also want to take a moment and
just share with you Trusty Gonzalez um
didn't expect to be here uh last night
after the board meeting when he got home
around 1:00. Um, his house was is full
of smoke. Um, was fire. Uh, so we've
been providing support. Um, he really
wishes he he could be here. So,
just wanted to kind of let y'all know
where that was going on in the
background.
So,
one of the things that we as a school
district are trying to do is to ensure
that every single student gets what they
need
to be successful academically.
And what I know and I think our board
knows is that for a very very long time,
Austin ISD has not been able to provide
the resources to ensure that occurs. not
across the entire district.
And so over the last many, many months,
we've been talking about strong
neighborhood schools. And there are
incredible things happening in Austin
ISD all the time. And that is absolutely
happening happening right here at Becker
Elementary School. There's no doubt. But
we know that what is happening here
isn't happening all across our district.
There are lots of families who have to
travel. They choose to travel because
they don't have a strong neighborhood
school where they live and it's our
responsibility, my responsibility to
ensure that that happens over time.
And so when we took on this work, there
were several things that we were
desperately trying to address all at one
time. Uh, and I want to kind of lay
those out at a high level just because I
think it's important just to communicate
the complexity of this plan and and the
reality that any time you make a change
in one part of the city, it impacts
adjacent schools. It impacts system as a
whole.
And so in this plan, you will see five
kind of big elements. The first being
aligning feeder patterns.
When we started this work, it was one of
our objectives to align our fear
patterns within Austin ISD.
Uh I've said this before and I will say
it I'm blew in the face. There are
schools in Austin where you go wholly
into another.
>> Think about Merkson or Anderson,
>> Ritzky and Taboui, right? The community
that gets built over time when you have
that type of alignment
ultimately moves systems. It moves our
community. But we don't have that in all
parts of Austin. We don't have that in
East Austin. We have middle schools that
go to four and five high schools. We
have elementary schools that go to three
and four middle schools. So our
objective was to align those speaker
patterns. And you can imagine the
disruption that causes when you type of
movements. Secondly, we wanted to
address our transfer policies.
Our policies in Austin IC have been in
place for a very very long time. Some of
them have created unintended
consequences.
All right? And we'll talk about what
that is kind of later on in the
conversation if it comes up. We really
needed to address it. You know, why do
do we have systems in place that are
allowing families to go path and
ultimately, you know, not view their
school as their home school. And again,
this is built up over decades. The third
thing we attempted to do was to address
um our budget. Now, I want to be really
really clear. These changes will not
close the deficit gap that we have. Just
not. It's not possible.
When 87% of your budget are people,
which is what it should be, it's our
teachers. It's our staff. You can't move
the needle in the way that you would
like, but you have to start and and get
to a point where you ultimately do have
a thriving system which requires a
balanced budget. And so over the last
two and a half years, we've been cutting
everywhere we can. We really have, but
at some point to a place where you have
to look at campuses and that's what
started this process. So consolidation
identifying efficiencies where there are
misalignments in our school system was
one of the other objectives in this
work. The fourth one program alignment
which I think is directly impacts
Becker. Obviously
it is understanding that over time the
intent of the program shifts the focus
of the program shifts because people
move city chambers. And so there are
real pressures that we as an
organization have to address moving
forward whether it's how we staff or the
requirements of ensuring a certified
teacher in one of our classrooms
or what student population is required
or need support of allocation to support
a program. So this is where wallto-all
dual language comes in as well as
monastery. Right? So that's why these
are in the plans and we'll talk
specifically around how that impacts
Becker. And then lastly, we have to be
honest about the fact that we are in an
evershifting accountability system in
the state of Texas.
In 23, in 22 and 23, you had 16 schools
that were an A that you know a B that
were in 23 an F. Think about that. 22
they were an A. 23 they were an F.
Sorry, BF. That's Apologies for that.
Brain is melting right now.
But they just same students like same
teachers.
>> And the honest truth is the influence
and authority that the state has to
require school districts to move through
a process to ensure that we don't have
those scarlet letters is something that
we have to manage because if we don't
then we absolutely are facing the real
risk of losing local control.
And it can happen. Our sister, our
sister school district in North Texas,
it's go it's happening right now. And so
I will tell you, I know our board and I
and our staff believe this. Whatever
happens in Austin ISD, our leaders, the
people that you have to be the ones that
provide the direction for the
organization. That has to be the case.
And so yes, turnaround plans, our
responses to them, opportunities within
the plan to ensure that we have plans
that are accepted are woven into this
process as well. And so it is complex.
There are lots of moving pieces. What
I've committed to the organization and
for those of you that know me, I am
100%
committed to ensuring that we take
input, we adjust, we refine, we improve.
No plan is perfect. No matter what we
do, it won't be perfect.
>> But the one thing that we cannot do is
just continue to delay.
What I will share with you that in my
experience here in Austin ISD, we're
really great at making plans. In the
last 50 years, we've made lots of them.
We're not that good at implementation.
And so as we move forward, one of the
things that I've observed is the reason
that occurs is because we make decisions
way too late in the process to give our
families time to plan. Like that is the
one thing we cannot give up is the
ability for our families to plan and our
our ability to ensure our work. So, um I
just wanted to share with you where we
are as a school district, why there are
so many things in this uh why it is on
this timeline.
I uh worked with our board. We've taken
feedback in the work session. Yes,
there's a draft that's coming out, an
updated draft that's coming out today,
the one that comes out next week as
well. You know, we are very thoughtful
about version control. I don't want to
go to one community and say, "Hey, we
made these changes." and then two days
later go a different community and then
share it with them and not have it go
through the entire system. So we are
very thoughtful and there were
deliverables that you you'll receive. Uh
you'll see red lines, you'll see the
connection to the comments. Every single
comment, every single conversation is um
cataloged evaluated and we will make
changes and we have and you'll see that
in the plan. [snorts] So we can go to
the next slide and then we'll I think
it's really important that we start we
kind of get to questions sooner than
later. A little sorry kind of a loud
talker. So um this is uh in the Becker
elementary school plan in the uh for
this approval we we are proposing that
the zone students the students that are
zoned to Becker are reassigned to Zilka
um and that the wallto-wall program
moves to Sanchez Elementary School.
So, a couple things I want to
communicate that uh kind of informed how
we got to this specific uh solution at
that time was the realization that you
know where are our margin bilingual
students? Where are they in our in our
school district? And what we know is
that in order to provide access to our
students and families who have
historically been underserved, we need
to move to where they are.
And so as an overall kind of
philosophical approach to movement of
programs,
we made that recommendation,
right? And we did it in a way and
created the placement in a way that
allowed for all the other dual language
programs because we have over 50 of them
to still be healthy, still be thriving.
At the same time, it also uh addresses
um a
requirement in our turnaround plan for
right. So, this is one of those things
where two kind of different objectives
in the plan are coming together.
I will say that um over the last few
weeks we've gotten lots of questions
about you know uh location uh distance
and we'll talk about that. We've gotten
questions around you know what happens
if the turnaround plan is approved but
you know the the pro doesn't move.
Reality is that you know the turnaround
plan for Sanchez still has to continue.
it has to uh and given the number of
turnaround plans that we have to
complete uh there's the real likelihood
that if there isn't a program moved
there then Sanchez would essentially be
a vacant building modernized building
and vacant for a period of time until we
moved another program in and that's just
a function of the the stress of the
system kind of setting these timelines
that we have to be responsive to. So we
can go to the next slide.
So, I I really want to make sure and and
um Travis, I'll kind of take your lead
here. I really want to make sure y'all
have time to answer questions. I will
tell you that we have questions that we
pulled from the comments that you
provided us, but I think it's really
really important that we hear from from
you. So, I'm happy to kind of continue
on, but if y'all have a desire to just
start having a conversation, I'm happy
to do that as well. I do not This is
your time together. I don't want you to
sit here and kind of listen to me talk.
Um, what would be most helpful?
>> Travis,
>> I figured that was probably the case.
Okay, y'all good with that? All right,
>> do we have a second mic?
>> Okay.
>> All right. Um
again, just to ask that we um keep our
comments to one minute. The if the
respondents from our panel will also try
uh just so that we can hear from as many
folks as possible. Okay,
>> I'm used to having the the count
Um, so your rubric shows that Becker is
predicted to have 509 students enrolled
next year. The draft plan states that
Becker can either go to Sanchez or the
Overflow, which is your terminology, uh,
school at uh, Overflow Immersion School
at JSON. My question is will there be
enough seats for the 509 Becker students
that are predicted to be enrolled
>> between Sanchez Odum and Joselyn? Yes,
there are enough seats for any current
dual language student here to enroll in
the program.
>> Followup question.
Um, I guess I'm confused because the
data shows that there will not be enough
seats um at Sanchez and Johnson to fit
the current Becker students um which uh
I've done the data looking at your
rubric and um the capacity at Sanchez is
532.
If um
there are 317 ED students that are
predicted to be enrolled there and you
currently have 106 English proficient
students there. If let's say roughly
half of those students stay, then that
means there's only 162 seats that will
be available at Sanchez. There's not
going to be any at ODM. I could go
through that data, but that'll take up
my 60 seconds. Um, and at Johnson right
now, they have a 412 capacity. And um,
they have 54 EB students and 193 that
are English proficient. And um if all of
the EB students stay plus let's say
again roughly half of the um the uh
English proficient students stay then
there will only be 262 open seats um at
Joslyn for us. The math doesn't seem to
add up. We're at least 50 to 60 students
short from that 5 and uh sorry one
moment 509 students that are there. And
so what looks to me is that we're going
to actually be fractured across not just
two two campuses but most likely more
than two if everybody remains in
district.
>> [applause]
>> So,
so one of the things that I'll say is um
in our observations as students move our
campuses merge uh the assumption that
the whole um you know actually is ends
up going uh is often not the case. um
not that and we also look at living and
resides and also have to acknowledge
that the there are going to be students
at Sanchez who can decide to go to
Zavala into Allison. Um this is this is
kind of where uh all of the the math
kind of comes together and then you
still have to look at what have you seen
historically. So based on kind of the
number and the percents either increase
net or or decrease below um what we've
seen in the past we are confident that
it will work. Um, I know it doesn't seem
because we're counting students, but the
reality is the way that students move in
a school system isn't 100% in any in any
direction at any one point. It just
doesn't happen that way. Families will
decide what is best for their students.
You all will decide what's best for your
student. um we do kind of assume
conservatively will occur which is why
we use those numbers and yes if you
break them down there's going to be some
exceedence but we as a district are
trying to kind of make the adjustments
and support our students in the increase
for a period of time and then over 15 20
years like the goal is to kind of
stabilize a system for the next 30 40
years. Um, so we understand that we have
looked at the data. Um, yes, you're
right. If you make those assumptions,
you are a little over. Uh, but we're
confident that it will work. Anything
else?
>> No, that's exactly right.
>> Hi, thanks for pushing the questions
forward because some of us have to go to
a a field trip. Uh, my name is Anne
Salivar. I have a pre-K4 and second
grader. I wanted to say two things. I
was hoping to dispel the myth conspiracy
theory I heard at Sunset Valley that a
bunch of us were going to try to move on
mass to ODM. Um, I've heard from other
parents that there are families who are
because we are the majority of us live
southwest Austin. Um, there are people
zoned to ODM. there are people in that
neighborhood that are zoned there doing
tours of the school. So, um I feel
really bad that we've been represented
as, you know, being entitled and trying
to take over. And I just want to
reassure you that that's not the
sentiment of all of the parents here.
Also, uh many people like myself will
not be able to go to Sanchez, not as a
rejection to the letter grade, but
because right now this is 15 minutes on
my way to work, as well as for my spouse
um to go to Sanchez, which we would
absolutely love to go with Mr. Barrett
and all of the exceptional teachers who
go above and beyond and in large part
because they're supported by families
that have the wonderful privilege of the
flexibility to be at meetings like this
because of their work schedules and
because of their economic situations. Um
we would love to go with the school and
I think it's going to hopefully be a
very successful experimentation on
raising the standards. Um, but we're not
able to just because going up and across
35, up and across the river is not
feasible for a lot of us. So, I just
want that to be on the record. It's not
a rejection, it's a feasibility issue.
And then secondly, sorry, I feel like
I'm talking too much. I just want to say
I said to uh Mr. Seagora, my family, we
transferred in from a title one oneway
dual language class. I know this I'm
going to take some heat for this, but I
want to sincerely say thank you. Uh we
last year [clears throat]
um in kindergarten my second grader had
an amazing teacher. God bless Miss
Gonzalez at Croseric Elementary. She had
prek4 and kinder 30 students at least.
She was an amazing teacher. In first
grade, our certified teacher had to
leave by November
uh suddenly without any warning. And
then the teacher that stepped in did her
best but was not fluent in Spanish. my
child had to act as a translator and nor
was uh she certified so she would miss
class to try to catch on certification.
So I really genuinely appreciate this
equity issue of and I look forward to
hopefully having certified bilingual
teachers with the kind of support the
teachers receive here at Becker at
schools like Casuric. Um, so thank you
very much and thank you to the Caseric
families because I am convinced 110% my
child's Spanish language as the only
non-native speaker in his class is why
he's fluent now. So thank you.
[applause]
Um I guess I will take just a quick
second to share that um the way that
this the enrollment system uh is and uh
will be does allow parents choice and so
we will hear from each of you in how you
rank um the programs uh and which round
you choose to um apply and register in
uh how where you want to end up. So, um,
if you are zoned to ODM, of course, we
respect zones first and foremost, and so
you have a spot at that school. Um, and
if you if there is another dual language
program uh that is more geographically
able uh for you to access um then the
way that you rank those programs will um
inform um the placements that we're able
to make. So, flexibility is built in
addition to the commitments that we are
making to schools that are moving and
changing.
Hi. Um, okay. You're expressing concern
um in your own words until you're blue
in the face for feeder patterns and the
disruption that it causes to communities
um who break apart. But in this plan,
Becker is being broken apart. You know
the data on where we live and you live
in the city, so you know how difficult
it is to cross the river at rush hour.
In fact, your math, as you've stated,
assumes that many of us do not go to
Sanchez. You've already built that in.
The assumption is that we break apart.
We go back into our neighborhood schools
and our children lose the dual language
that they have worked so hard for and
they lose the community that you are
trying to avoid or you're trying to
prevent using for others by fixing these
feeder patterns.
With that in mind, will you please
consider letting us combine with Dawson?
Closing two neighborhood schools next to
each other
is painful. Zilker has a very difficult
time keeping their dual language program
alive because it's so small and we've
spoken with many families at their
campus who would be glad to have the
choice to choose between a combined
Becker Dawson dual language program and
staying with their friends at Zilker.
They understand that they may not be
able to keep dual language alive at
Zilker for for much longer. This would
solve the pro the immediate overcrowding
problem at Zilker that's going to happen
with new lines being drawn. It would
help their community stay together and
it would solve for the two neighborhood
schools being closed next to each other
and all of the EB and Heritage families
who live in this community. Will you
please consider letting us combine
>> [applause]
>> Oh, sorry. I just I want to make sure
I'm looking to So, thank you for that.
Uh, this came up at the board meeting um
the work session about exploring it and
we are committed to exploring all
feedback that comes from our our our
communities and it's also very helpful
when there are solutions that you all
provide to us or ideas. I mean because
you know the community best. What I will
say is each and every time that we
analyze um these
proposed solutions I have to be really
clear to our trustees kind of what
change in the overall goals it is going
to be kind of considered. Um so we are
looking at it. Uh can speak to it more
than I can. Um, I will kind of
acknowledge, you know, the emerging
bilingual student population, even at
Dawson, still isn't as dense as it is
elsewhere in the city. I I hear you
about heritage families. Um, but the
emerging bilingual student population
kind of is the focus for the foundation
of the program. Uh and when we look at
projections and movement of students, I
think we just have to acknowledge that
there may become a point in that plan in
the recent future, which would be
further away in a different plan where
we're just not able to allocate the
staff because a there's a very very few
um staff available as a whole that are
certified dual language compared to the
number of educators that we have and
we're competing for them all the time.
uh but we are going to look at it and
then I'd also have to solve for Sanchez
um because one of the things that we
wanted to do is to make sure that we
kept a thriving neighborhood thriving
school in that community as well um
while addressing the tap in a modernized
facility. So I just have to work through
that but the board did ask for that as
well um and we are working through it.
So we'll have a response but yeah I mean
I I want to refine and improve. I just
want to be really honest about kind of
what the exchange is and our trustees
will will be able to kind of provide
that. Yes.
>> So, Mr. Sagura, you said a lot of that,
right? and we you know that we are
looking at areas that have a higher
density of emergent bilingual students.
But I also want to say that it's very
important to us that we know we've got
1100 families just in the four current
wallto-w walls that have made a
commitment that are non-emergent
bilingual families to participate in
dual language programming. And so that
was very much a factor when we were
looking at potential solutions. Right?
it was with those 1100 families that we
have across the district at the current
four wallto-w walls that are
participating in dual languages
non-emergent bilingual. So, so that was
factored in um again just talking about
um the sustainability right of uh
long-term and that is also really
driving our decisions
in the documentation.
>> Great idea. So just a one other thing to
clarify on that. I think what our
proposal says is to not instead of
Sanchez, it would be in addition to
Sanchez, so a fifth dual language school
for South Central Austin. Just to clarif
I think have been very clear in uh not
advocating for any other school
closures, but just uh representing why
we think that a wall-to-wall dual
language program in South Central Austin
Makes sense.
>> Just want to make that quick. Um,
>> yep. Go ahead. No, please.
>> I don't want to. It's your time. I don't
want She was getting out of
>> Um, so they stole all my questions. Uh,
so, okay, here's one. Uh so I think one
of the things that I'd like to
understand from the district is you know
when when we talk about programs and uh
obviously wallto-wall dual language uh
monastery uh single gender uh that all
kind of gets lumped together. But when
you double click into that, dual
language actually is more profitable per
student than some of these other
programs like Monasur because of the
additional state funding. And so I I
guess I do take a little bit of issue
with like lumping that all together
because it is different even when you
subtract for the additional $7,000 that
you have to pay each teacher uh for that
certification. So if you could just talk
a little bit about Yeah.
>> Yeah. No. So
>> um So I I very I very much appreciate um
kind of the the question or the the
comment because I most people don't
break them apart as far as different
types of programs we have. So I have
kind of communicated that way out but
you're absolutely right. Uh Monasuri
does not um have a different allocation
um as we coach students who are
identified as um emerging bilingual
receiving dual language uh you know
education from the state. And so you're
absolutely right. There are different
costs for different programs. A single
gender um that is very different you
know because we have two we have Gus
Garcia we have we have and Richards um
we we we
don't look at them all together just to
be clear. Uh but when we communicate
around programming as a whole most
communities kind of identify different
programs and pull them together. That's
why I communicated that way. We don't
look it that way. I I agree with you.
You're 100% right. uh we do get
additional funding for the students that
are in this program this specific
program.
>> Okay.
>> And and I would also say that um every
time uh the a program uh also
contributes to the cost um per student.
So
>> we staff to language
>> um one of the things that's unique to us
is that we commit we make that
commitment. Uh, so if you have a school
that's running, you know, different
programs and we're staffing by language
or by program, then all of a sudden you
could have four classrooms, each one of
them be 14, 15 or 18 students, but if
they were all the same program, you
probably would be able to reduce, you
know, one teaching allocation. So, so we
we make those adjustments and that's why
the um it doesn't always tell the whole
story. You have to kind of get into the
weeds spit all, but you're you're right.
I just want to make that kind of note
like the more complex a program is at a
school more costly it's going to be
>> and then second question is really
around the the identifying where the
emergent bilingual students are right
that was a big driver in why uh you know
we're going to Sanchez and so you know
obviously you guys have more data to
look at than we do but by by our math
central and south central Austin does
have a strong emergent bilingual program
and Even if you go zip code versus zip
code that's we're at least equal with
the Sanchez zip code uh because of you
know the gentrification and the Airbnbs.
>> Yeah. So
>> yeah so I I was going to share too that
we were looking at um with the
demographers like density right the heat
map um just density. So there are
emergent bilingual students in the
south. there are they're a little more
spread out. It's not as dense, right, as
some areas when we talk about that kind
of southeast pocket, right? There's
several schools around there that have
higher numbers of emergent bilingual
students. So together that that area has
more like more dense. I also wanted to
just clarify something about staffing.
So I appreciate Mr. Sagura talking about
we have made a commitment as a district
to staff our programs, right? So it does
maybe bump up another classroom, another
teacher allocation.
Right now, you know, it's not just um
unique to Austin ISD. We have a shortage
of bilingual educators. Every year by
November 1st, each district needs to
submit the number of teachers who are on
waiverss or exceptions. That means
bilingual exceptions, teachers that
don't have their bilingual
certification, right? that they're maybe
in route to get their certification or
teachers that don't have their ESL
certification, [crying]
they're on route to get it. So, Austin
ISD this year is reporting over 400
teachers without like bilingual
exceptions or um ESL waiverss. And so,
again, our state is moving towards
ensuring it's our goal as well, but at
the state is also moving to ensuring
that our teachers have their
certification very quickly. So that did
not drive a lot of this but as we have
these conversations and I appreciate the
questions you're asking right we also
have to consider like other pieces that
are happening as well.
>> Absolutely. And so the one last thing
I'll say is our proposal does include as
part of it, you know, having a program
that increases and has a track a
pipeline if you will of dual language
certifications from recruiting from like
UT Rio Grande Valley&M like we've talked
to some of those uh campuses and have
them come in and and maybe come to a
place like Becker uh get certified, get
mentored, and then go into other parts
of the community or the district um as
[clears throat] part of our our
proposal. So, just
>> thank you so much. [applause]
>> Hi, thank you all for being here. Um so,
he kind of stole my question about where
the EBS are. Um, however, if you look at
the Sanchez area, there's million-dollar
homes and Airbnbs all around it. and
your proposal is going to start
transporting EBS to Sanchez and
recruiting at Sanchez to keep that 50/50
ratio. This is something that we've been
asking for for 5 years and now we're
being penalized for not having enough
EBS. When there are enough EBS in 7704,
[applause] the percentage of EBS is
smaller, but percentage can be
deceiving. We have more by number based
on your own data. As well as we have
more seats per EB than we do on 7872.
So, I'm asking, why did we not get that
five years ago? Why didn't we get the
transportation, the recruiting, and the
help to get to the 50-50 ratio? And why
are you penalizing us today?
[applause]
>> So, thank you for your question. One of
the pieces that we're moving into that
is new is an unzoned campus, right? So,
we haven't had that in the past. Right
now, Becker is zoned and four wallto-
walls are zoned. And so priority will
always go to the zoned families, right?
It that is how we're built. That's how
it works. And we want families to go to
their neighborhood school. That does um
somewhat prohibit any any like entry
point like how do you then So this is
the plan for the unzed. We are actually
going to set do the enroll Austin system
where as applications come in we're
looking at at least 50% of the seats
right to go to emergent bilingual
students and up to 50% to go to the
non-emergent bilingual. We can set those
parameters with an unzone campus which
is not what we were able to do at zoned
campuses.
>> But I guess that why couldn't we do that
here with this? We have the we same
number of EBS in 7874 than 7872. And if
you look at the data, most of the EBS
most likely because we don't have the
demographers data live south of the
river which is a barrier. So it they
don't live right in that immediate area.
Um so so I guess I'm wondering why is
that not feasible for Becker?
No, I I do want to state and maybe
Rachel can tell us better, but there are
students that are currently attending
Sanchez that might be a little to the
south or a little to the west like in
different in different areas. So, they
are currently receiving transportation
and currently attending Sanchez. So,
we're considering all of the students in
that area. I don't know what their zip
codes are.
So, I just wanted to share some Becker
specific information that's related to
what's been shared. We talked about the
bilingual exemptions and waiverss.
Currently, we have nine teachers that
fit that category here today. Uh it's
been an ongoing challenge since co with
teacher turnover, teachers leaving the
industry. I do believe that we've done
an exceptional job here mentoring new
staff and and building their capacity,
but staffing has been a huge challenge
and recruitment has been something that
I have prioritized every year and talent
strategy or human resources has
supported that. I have gone to El Paso,
I have gone to Laredo, uh I have gone to
the different universities in central
Texas to recruit and it's not as easy as
it sounds. Uh when I'm in El Paso
talking to candidates, recent graduates
there, they're like 9 hours is a long
ways and my my family's like this. I
that's that's a hard cell for me. I get
the same response from candidates from
Laredo. San Antonio, we have a little
bit more luck, but it's an hour hour and
a half away. But recruitment is really
challenging and the district, myself,
and our talent strategy have put a lot
of time and effort into recruiting. Um
so just put that out there for a little
bit. Um there's one other thing that I
think is important to understand. I a
lot of the dialogue I have seen is about
the wall campus as opposed to a campus
that has like one strand or a couple of
classrooms that are bilingual classrooms
but also have ESL at a grade level.
There's an assumption I think that the
wall to wall programs are better. Um so
I'll give you a specific data point. Um,
my wife is the principal at Casey
Elementary. I compete with her all day,
every day on our data. And last year's
data shows that the dual students on her
campus are performing better than our
dual language students. So, there is
access to dual language programs at
campuses that are not wall-to-wall, but
it doesn't mean that they're not as good
as this one.
>> [applause]
>> So, if you're asking about five years
ago, why this is I think one of the
things that we're running into now is we
are we are having to make bigger
decisions because we made we didn't make
decisions in the past. I can't speak to
that. The board wasn't here. I wasn't
here. Um but there are lots of things
that we're running into now that we wish
we would have addressed decades ago,
five years ago, etc. Um regarding
density of students, um you know, we
have the maps. We don't share them
broadly because we don't want we for
various reasons. Um, but our trustees
have seen them, we have seen them, we
obviously work with them. Um, I'm happy
to maybe figure out if there's a way I
can communicate percentages or maybe a
way to communicate density to kind of
just kind of share at a high level um
why it is different there than here. Um,
but that's probably the best I can do,
but we'll work.
>> Hey, Matias, thank you for the chat this
morning. Hey.
>> Yeah. Sorry. Um, so there are some
families who need to go on a field trip.
They are chaperoning and they are asking
um if the folks who don't have to leave
would seed and so that they can speak
first. Would that be okay? Okay.
All right. So, anybody who feels really
strongly that you would like to speak
before you have to leave.
>> Okay. We're gonna let this
>> I'm so sorry. And I I stopped.
>> No, no, you're you're fine.
Um,
I just want to say thank you so much for
being here and taking your time and I
really appreciate the words that Mr.
Barrett just shared about the other
programs around the district. And that's
actually my question. Um, I understand
while a I echo everyone's thoughts on
would loving the idea of maintaining
some continuity with Becker in the south
central Austin. Um, as a family that
does commute from southwest Austin, um,
I have a pre-K4er and I know that I
actually have heard I know Oakill has a
strong EB program and that there are
there there is that demographic um, that
supports that as well. And I was curious
if there is any discussion about whether
students that are maybe like were zoned
to patent but believe strongly in EB if
we could be considered or if maybe those
like Casey or Oakill if those have been
considered at all um for expanding their
dual language program to accept more
children.
So um we are currently we're reviewing
right so um dual language programs that
we have now um I do want families to
understand and so thank you for asking
that question um your question is about
expanding we're looking into that but it
also is a good reminder that there are
campuses out there and you all will be
able to apply also right if there is a
dual language campus
then please also um take advantage of
the application for that.
>> Yes. So, so I guess is there
consideration at those places for I know
we're talking about non-zoned, but um I
am just curious like
>> I know that like Oak Hill is pretty full
is the reason.
>> Yeah. So um for those of y'all that were
following along in the board meeting uh
super late at night, not this last one
last night, but the one before that was
through this week. Oh yeah.
>> Um the whole time.
>> So there was a kind of a philosophical
question regarding how AISD leans into
dual language, right? We we do and we
talk about that all the time. I'm very
proud of it, but we're we're making
changes based on a program that had been
built for years and hadn't really been
adjusted uh in a in a pretty significant
way. And so there have been questions
that I've gotten from trustees uh
questions that we've had as a team
about, you know, what is the proper way
to ensure that we have more access, but
that's also so that it's sustainable,
right? And as Principal Barry just said,
it's it doesn't have to always be a
wall-to-wall program. Uh we are going to
spend time kind of going through that.
we're going to be looking at magnets.
There's lots of other large programs
that we as a district have to take on
and just assess and figure out is this
how we're going to provide um this
support or is it going to look something
a little bit different. Um you probably
you probably heard that comment at the
at the work session or maybe it was in a
different meeting but that is one thing
we have to really really think through.
Unfortunately, what I would say is in
this moment because of where we started,
we were working with what we had. Um,
and so we we have how many campuses have
dual language? 58
58 right now. Um, the question becomes,
you know, how do you create kind of this
type of experience um in other schools
without having to go all the way to wall
wallto- wall and then what is that cost
going to be? And then how do I create
the resources to be able to support it
long term? That's the question. Um, and
I know Trusty Singh and Trusty Kaufman
are like hyperfocused on making sure
that we kind of go there. Um, but that's
going to occur over the next probably 18
months, but we have them. We're
investing in them, providing resources,
but expansion is always a question
because I don't want to expand something
until I know we can do it well.
>> I 100% I just wanted to throw that out
there because I feel like that has been
something that hasn't been addressed.
And I also want to say that I appreciate
everything you all have done. I
understand from working in business how
sometimes there can just be a clatic
cataclysmic event that happens and I
know we have three things going on. So I
sympathize with that and I want to say
like I my home schools are getting
resold and I'm I'm fine with point like
I'm excited to go to Crockett and
excited to change that and I know
there's people that have been concerned
about that. But I do want to say one
thing that I don't know if y'all have
taken into consideration and this has
nothing to do with Becker, but simply
the fact that like our voting lines do
not match with like even our home
schools. So for example, like we vote
for I vote in Legend Oaks for Kaufman,
but all my schools zoned currently and
future are not under him as the trustee.
And so I think that can be confusing. It
can be great like maybe we have more
advocates but at the same time like
those pathways do not match if that
makes sense.
>> Yeah. So um because there are two
different data sets that are driving um
you know the decision for each. The
first is the census right the where
people live. Uh that is what drives the
um the work that kind of realigns
boundaries for our trustees. They did
that at the 2020 census. Um for our work
it it is a little more complicated than
that, right? It's not only where um
people live, but it's where students
are. It is kind of acknowledging that
people and families move through the
city a different way. There's alignment
in programming. Uh so they don't always
match. They're never going going to
match. I've never seen them match really
unless it's a really really small school
district. Um but yeah, that's the
reason. Uh I don't know that we'll ever
get to a place where they match totally.
Um but I wanted to and it's always a
balance of population. So you can have a
high school that has a less dense
population and then because census is
really based on density of of people um
you're going to see that shift. So so
that they're just never going to match.
But we try to do our best to kind of
create balance within the high schools
that each has a certain number of high
schools as best we can but they're two
different data sets.
>> So do you just like write all three
then? Because like I would be writing to
Kaufman, Boswell and Gonzalez.
>> I I
>> is that like serious? Like I mean it's a
serious question.
>> No, I I would Yes. Three. I would say
>> three for sure.
>> Yeah. Okay. I'm just It's just a cur.
It's just a It's just a like
>> Yeah.
>> Who's advocating for you? It's pretty.
>> Thank you.
>> They are all advocating all the time.
>> Mas, thanks for the chance to chat
beforehand. And our our discussion was
about big picture. Big picture, your
legacy, your financial wisdom, you know,
how you want to be remembered. This
portion is going to be more Becker
specific. Put my Becker hat on. My wife
Jenny and I are 16ear Becker families
contiguous. Our fourth child is in
fourth grade. So we've been here for 16
years. Started in 2011. I was on the
dual language advisory council, the very
first one, one of two parents in 2010 to
choose the four pilot dual language
schools. Becker being one. That was the
catalyst that changed the school to make
it what it is today. and the people you
see around you. But the history lesson
goes farther back 1936 and I'm sure and
hope you guys know this. This is sold by
one dollar from the Herman Becker to the
school district at the time. Fast
forward now the Herman Becker
descendants have made a statement which
I hope you've written by our neighbor
our neighborhood communities told you
this. They intend for this campus to
remain as a public education. So pause
there. What do you guys do about that
history? Herman Becker sold this to the
district for $1 in 1936. It should
remain a public educational facility.
[applause]
>> I'm going to talk loudly and hopefully
it carries. Um, couple things.
>> I'll keep the mic then.
>> A couple things. So, the first and
foremost is that
>> yours.
>> Oh, man. That's harsh.
And I'll um so uh the reality is that
yes there there are different um things
that are tied to to different
properties. Um, whenever we think about
repurposing, whenever we think about
what the next kind of version of a of
the history of a campus or a site is, we
work with the community. We identify,
okay, what makes sense? Um, educational
to purpose, uh, we went through that
process a couple different times in our
history here just recently, uh, with
Austin ISD. I would say most recently,
the time that we went through it is when
Peas actually closed, right? the state
of Texas, I think 1887 had said peace
elementary school will be designated as
an educational um space or facility and
we acknowledge that. So we went through
the process. It wasn't an elementary
school but we ultimately were able to
work with Congressman Dogget um find
funds, repurpose and then move it and
have it become an early childhood
center. So I just want to you know I
don't I know that when we talk about
repurposing and real estate lots of
folks kind of get all the way to the end
around you know sale what is it going to
be you know that that's not what drove
any of this it was really about trying
to find overall systematic improvements
but anytime we go through a community
will be involved um regarding legality
or kind of what's in title or you know
kind of what commitments are are on the
property that's that's not even
something that we would have spent I'm
going through because a it's not a vote
and b we would ever we would do we would
do with you. Um but we have different
ways to to kind of still activate sites.
We just wouldn't operate it as a
traditional elementary school. Um
>> I I I didn't look at the I didn't look
at the title of all the camp. I just
don't have that.
I mean, so we have the authority to
operate this split operate as we need.
>> Public and free school.
>> All right.
>> Awesome. She's a smart.
>> Okay. So, I mean I I if that's the case,
that's I understand that. I mean, I
don't I don't know what you would want
me to say at this moment except that we
would have to go through that process,
determine kind of what meets the
requirements in that statement. It's
entitled. It was a a statement made by
the family. I I I so
in Austin ISD just to be clear.
[applause]
So I will I will tell you in Austin ISD
given the fact that we're 144 years old
almost every property we have has been
given to us by some land owner by some
family. That's just the honest truth. We
have 106 we have 132 properties across
the city. Most of them are like that.
Um, and so we we navigate it. We work
with the community. Um,
>> well, so if you go before the fact and
the question becomes, are you selling
property? Are you repurposing and then
make a decision to close the school.
That's not what we're going to do. We're
not we're not going to talk about how
much something is worth or what we're
going to do with it. Educational
purposes first and then we work with
committee to figure out what the
solution is going to be for that site.
Um, then, you know, if it's in title,
then we'll work through it. I mean,
we're not going to break. We're going to
do it the right way. Um, but we wouldn't
just given how all these properties are.
That's pretty kind of familiar to us.
Like that's something you're running
into quite a bit.
[applause]
>> Okay.
Got it.
>> All right. Um, just for everyone, the
microphones are designed to cut if sense
a voice
and so keeping them.
>> Attendance reminder, please log into
Frontline and be ready to submit your
attendance when the bell rings at 9:45.
>> Attendance taking
we'll pause for that announcement and I
will hand it over to Miss Vasquez.
Hi, my name is Miss Vosquez. I am a PE
teacher here at Becker. Um, no, I can
hold it. [cheering]
[applause]
Um, I am an or was an AISD student, AISD
alumni, and I'm a current uh grad school
student at UT Austin for educational
policy and planning. Uh when I watched
the workshop meeting, Trusty Singh
brought up how there are campuses that
have a dual language program but do not
have the needed biling educators. Now by
creating four new non-zone campuses, are
we creating an even bigger strain on the
critical demand? We have kiddos also in
ESL classes that don't have a bilingual
teacher. Um Trusty Foster noted that
non-zone schools can inequitable over
time because they lack a defined
community base. It is the hope is the
hope for the families at these projected
non-school campuses to stay. Now, to my
knowledge, there is yet to be a
Is it still working? There you go. Uh
for a campus visit like in community
outreach, this is an absolute necessity.
What guardrails will the district
implement to ensure that these new zones
will provide a quality dual language
program on the east side? It's
imperative that the district prepares
for additional incentives to recruit our
current AISD beling educators to high
need areas and to attract more to our
district. It's also important for our
district to prepare for how in to H1B
visas could affect the national B
teachers we currently receive. I spent a
decade Kamacho activity center on Robert
T. Martinez and Holly Street and
how quickly this neighborhood has been
gentrified. The fact that Sanchez, named
after a Mexican-American civil rights
activist who campaigned for educational
equality, remains 91% Hispanic is an act
of resistance and one worth protecting.
Oh no, I pressed something. I'll sit
down. Um, one thing I'm curious about is
if previous consolidations
uh are any special cons consideration to
campuses that have already gone through
a consolidation process recently. And
finally, I encourage the district to
provide campuses with a transparent road
map outlining what happens if we don't
meet key funding benchmarks in the next
legislative session. Our proximity to
the capital is an asset and our families
need to know what's at stake. I have
full faith that given how our
communities have already mobilized
districtwide during this season, we
could have a serious and positive impact
on public education funding across the
state of Texas. I care about the
sustainability of the district as a
whole, and I'm asking you to do this
right and minimize harm. And I know that
we can't control um Sanchez having the
accountability ratings, but I think we
can control that they're being fractured
into four different schools um
and that there hasn't been community
engagement as far as a campus visit
there.
[applause]
I'm going to start and then hand it on
over to you. I just want to I want to
say that you're right about a lot of
what you just said. Um, we are we are
currently like we we have been and not
just currently looking to see where our
high needs campuses are, where the
staffing needs to be, where the
resources need to be to be able to
support those campuses, right? And so I
I thank you for asking the question and
stating that because that's exactly what
we're doing on our end. Um, it really is
a prioritization, right, of the students
and the communities that need um our
bilingual teachers the most, right? So
we we are looking at it and have been
looking at it. Going to pass it on over.
>> No, I mean I mean you you you said it
well. The only thing I would um my only
response would be is we we have been
fighting. You know, I don't want anybody
here to think that we have not been
fighting desperately tooth and nail the
last many years to have the state
provide additional support. You know,
one of the things that's kind of added a
lot of pressure recently is just the
changes in the federal government's
policies. whether it's title funding or
the way immigration is being addressed
that has put severe pressure on this
system. Um we do not want to create
harm. Uh but it's going to happen. I
acknowledge that through any big change
and the way that you can mitigate that
is have thoughtful plans and have time.
You've got to have time to actually
ensure those plans are thoughtful,
they're ethical, they support our
community, support our students, and
that we can actually deliver. Um and so,
you know, I appreciate the comment and
I'm right there with you. Thanks.
So yeah, I feel like it like if this
came out like during the legislative
sessions, our parents could have gone to
like the people who have the power to
provide funding. Um or like they're
sitting on a surplus budget. And so I
think it would just be nice to know
like, okay, if we get this much funding,
this is what it means for for our
district. If we receive this much
funding, this is what it means for our
district. So then that way when people
go, they they know what's on the line.
And I know that there has to be a
balance because we don't want to like
have like fear amongst our our our
families, but um I just think that we
need more people at the ledge. And not
just us. I know you were there. I was
there. We were all there, but we need
more people there. We need to build our
army.
[applause]
>> Hi everybody. being here. Um
uh my name is Anel Buhanda. I'm
a Becker parent. I'm a former um Austin
ISD bilingual teacher
always in title one schools rumb area.
Um and I'm saying all that because I
will talk as a parent and as a former
teacher.
I want to start by like thanking all the
amazing professionals in this school.
I've been blessed, privileged.
I like I'm thankful beyond belief to
them. My gifts have been the privilege
to be here and have an amazing and
outstanding public education. because of
them because of the administration that
is leader too and I want to thank them
there and because of the district that
is the ultimate responsible of all this
happening. So I want to start there
making like that really clear. I want to
thank you too for explaining all the
pressures that are leading us into this
situation where we have a big budget
surf and force us to make hard decisions
and thank you for incorporating the
feedback. Uh I was telling Matias before
that incorporating the short-term
decision is what we do with the schools.
The long-term strategic plan is to
defend our public system in terms of
education and incorporating community
feedback into this plan is what's going
to work for our long term to have our
community
identifying with public education and
defending public education. So I
appreciate that. Um,
in terms of this amazing staff that we
have here at Becker, Becker is impacted
or he may be impacted. We hope he's not
impacted. Worst scenario comes through
and we need to close
a high performing, academically high
performing and lowcost school, something
that has been achieved by all these
amazing professionals.
If that comes to happen, my question is
what's the plan of the district to
ensure that staff at Becker, whether
that's cafeteria staff, custodians,
people at the uh front office, teachers,
administration, everybody from the
bottom to top, they play in an even
playing field.
They have done an amazing job as good or
better than anybody else in any other
school. How do we set up even playing
field for them
to keep their jobs and positions, right?
We want the best people to stay in ISD.
Was the district plan for that?
[applause]
>> So, I got it. I can
>> I just wanted to say one thing. Um I
just wanted to do a time check. We will
stay. I know that Matias will stay.
However, um if we can uh cap the line,
so if you are my caboose in elementary
school terms, uh right there and uh and
then that way um we also know that this
meeting was scheduled until 10:00. And
so if there's um I I asked to cap the
line um uh we really we've got like 9
minutes left officially and if people
need to um go then of course we
understand. Uh if you slip up, I'm
sorry.
>> I will I will I will stay here. I if we
have I don't know when this space will
be used, but I will I will be here till
we we have the conversation.
>> Okay. Um are we okay there?
>> I'm just I'm checking with the group.
Are we okay there?
>> Okay.
>> All right. Thank you. Um, so I'm going
to try to be brief in my responses and
very direct. Um, we immediately when we
released the plan also provided a a uh a
structure for how we're going to go
through the hiring process in the
staffing process to ensure that all of
our staff the the the unit of change in
our school district is [clears throat]
supported and protected through this
process. We we provided that
deliverable. Um, if you look at the
deliverable, I'm happy to to have um
Barretts or Travis, sorry, you Travis.
um uh send it out. But what it says is
this is the staffing plan for this
transition. If it's a turnaround plan,
there will be certain requirements. If
it's a programmatic move, there'll be
certain requirements. If it's a
traditional consolidation, it may look a
little bit different. Um we are going to
hire or I am going to select the
principal in December. Like it's
important that we do that at that point
so that that leader can then begin to go
through and hire their staff. Um, we at
no point have ever said that a single
person who is not already with Austin
ISD wouldn't be able to stay. I' I've
said that from the beginning and there
was like a post somewhere about we're
going to get fire 700 people. That's
ridiculous. We never said it. Never
entered our mind. That's not something
we would ever ever do. We hire almost
700 teachers every single year. We have
the ability given our size to ensure
that everybody has a home. Now, I want
to be really really clear. there will be
a focus on where the students are. So
the students go students from school A
go to school B. We would want familiar
faces in school B because those students
who came from school A had that
experience with their educators which is
why placing the principal is important
to do early. So you have that commitment
from me. It's in the documentation.
We're going to go through the
placements. We are not opening external
hires until late April. So, we're going
to go through the staffing pro process
through January and February. Anybody
that doesn't um have a home, uh we will
then begin to look at other campuses
throughout the district. Uh and then go
through match fairs and at the end
before we open up a single position to
the anybody outside the district, we
will go and do placements if there is
not someone didn't find a home. But I'm
very confident that the vast majority
who want to stay here will have a
placement at that time. The only thing
I'll say also is we are sending a
survey. Um, we've had lots of educators
and principles and staff say, "Hey, I
live in North Austin, but I've been
working in South Austin for 20 years. I
want to try something different." We're
taking all of that in consideration as
we go through this process and it's all
laid out in that plan. That's my
commitment. Um, I we we've never looked
at contracts. We That's not So, so we we
have a thoughtful plan. That's how we're
going to do it and it's all documented.
We get more updates, we'll refine it and
improve it.
>> Still, I'm gonna just double click on
that one. So, somebody who is here
that has done a fantastic job for years
now is going to have to be looking for a
job because this school has been
impacted for the greater good of Austin
ISD. While somebody that is in a school
that has not been impacted is not going
to have to be looking for a job.
>> So, they have their job secure. But like
people here, they don't.
So whenever you I'm looking at
transition between so if if there's an
educator in a campus not going through
consolidation I'm not going to ask them
to participate because they're already
at a a school. I mean that that
principal has hired their staff right in
transitions like this right or any one
of them in our plan the leader of the
campus with significant support from the
administration is going to kind of set
the expectation for hiring. You know
what we don't want to have happen is get
to a place where all of a sudden the
staff who have been here supporting
those students aren't at the school
where those students went.
>> That's what we have to avoid. So that is
going to be the priority. Now that may
not happen because there's a different
choice or perhaps blending two schools
and there are some educators that you
know just aren't needed given the number
of the student population. Then we would
work around and go based on preference
and then start that process. Uh, that
goes for custodial staff, it goes for
food service staff, it goes for
everybody. I mean, we we hire lots of
folks. We have lots of opportunities to
protect positions. I've been really
clear from the beginning. If you want to
be with Austin ISD, you will have a
home. What I can't do is guarantee I
like guarantee it, guarantee it. I mean,
you know, that that's kind of one of
those things where never say that just
because it's but that's our intent. The
board understands it. I understand it.
We have a plan in place. We'll execute
it that way.
>> I got it. Yeah. It's not about
guaranteeing. is about like having the
same opportunities, right? Because
>> I would say that the staff would
actually have be prioritized because
we're holding any external positions or
any other hires until those staff are
placed first.
>> Thank you so much. Thank you. Appreciate
it. Thank you.
>> I want to speak to that from the
principal perspective, right? Um,
staffing has been a significant
challenge for the several years. And as
I talk to candidates and reach out, get
their resumes, um, I often hear things
like, "You're the 15th principal that's
called me." Um, right now it is a
teachers market. Um, I'm highly invested
in our staff. I've had a lot of
conversations with our staff. Um, I have
committed my 100% support to help ensure
they all land in a place that they are
happy to be in. Um, I can't guarantee it
like Matia said, but that is a
commitment of mine. And because our
staff is so dedicated and hardworking,
they will be highly sought after in this
transition. You all know that. So, we
have a great team and we will support
them in any way we can. I've told them
like
on the one hand, I don't want to start
over. This is year six for me here and
we've built something really great with
this team. Uh I want to continue to do
the work with the people that I'm doing
the work with. Uh but there will be
changes if the plan moves forward and as
we navigate those changes, they will
still have my full support.
[applause]
>> Okay, this is kind of the same for him.
I've been working here like for 14
years. I'm in the cafeteria.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
[applause]
My question is like I'm been here like
14 years. Um
where am I going to go next basically
because I don't like this school to
close. I've been here like for too many
years for them to close it down. But is
there any way that we can save it? And
where where's
[applause]
>> you're amazing. Um you're you're
absolutely incredible. Uh people like
staff like you you
like I just I love you like that. That's
that's exactly who we are as a school
district. Thank you so much. Um you've
given your career to Austin ISD to
Becker. Um and there are lots of people
like you and that's who I am going to
protect. Um, I can't tell you where
where you're where you're going to go
because we don't know yet um what's
going to happen. You know, we're going
to go through that process. But I can
promise you that Christine, the
operations officer, myself, who was over
all of food service, not well, I guess
I'm technically still all over over all
of food service. Um, I'm going to make
sure that our staff, those who've been
here with us, uh, you know, share our
values, share our culture, are
supported. Um, and our first goal is
going to make sure that you have
familiar faces and familiar people
around you in any mood. That's the goal.
I won't be able to do it in every case
just because, you know, when you bring
people together, there's not that many
spots. But then we will ask you, you
know, get us like what do you want to
do? And then we will make sure that you
get to a place that is comfortable and
right for you. But
>> I mean I don't think it's is it counts.
I want to hear something like from you
that is definely like if they move to
Sanchez are we going to move with them
or wherever they move are we going to
move them or we're going to see
different faces like I've been here like
a long time and I see my kids go fifth
grade to middle school. I mean, I have
them like from prek with their babies. I
can still have the pictures and all
that. Not and to me, it's sad for me to
see them leave and I want that's all I
wanted to know if we're going to go with
them or we're going to school like you
said. I mean, it's hard to say, but are
we going to have like something with all
even some familiar faces?
>> Yes, that that that is my goal 100%.
That that's what we want. We we we want
our students to see you like the ones
here wherever they go see you in the
line, see you as you move to the school.
That's what we want. Um so I appreciate
you and this I that's my commitment to
you. So just thank you. No, thank you.
No. [applause]
Hi. [applause] Good morning. Okay. I
have two concerns and I'm going to try
to go as quickly as possible. I'm going
to stand by my husband because I get
nervous. Um, okay. So, our first ask
when everything started, we all came
together and we said, "Please keep us
together as a community no matter what."
[applause]
And then I don't believe that a heat map
was actually done as to where we all
live. So, here is the heat map.
the [applause] the school that was
chosen for us is geographically
infeasible.
And so,
thanks guys. Um, so a poll was done and
only 14% of parents can make it to
Sanchez. You have over 30% of parents
that are going to try to get into ODM.
you have another additional that are
probably going to leave the district or
that want to go to Jocelyn or that will
go to their own their own schools. So, I
know that the first speaker brought up
here um that worried if there's going to
be enough space and I know you said yes,
there's going to be enough space. When
the math is done, there's not going to
be enough space. Um with ODM, for
instance, that that's 30% of us more.
That's roughly around 150 students that
were going to want to go to ODM. It was
also said that Odin would keep it
wouldn't be completely wallto-all. They
would have Sunset Valley Go. You would
also have an English track. there's
there's just not the space and there's
not the space at Dawson either. So my
additional concern is that at the end of
the day we're going to be told, hey,
just go to your neighborhood school
because they have we have 50 dual
language programs. I was an educator in
Austin and I was a bilingual teacher.
And there is a huge difference between a
one-way bilingual program and a two-way
bilingual program. And mo [applause]
most Hold on, we're almost done. I
promise. Um, and most of the when we
called all of the schools, they are
mostly one way and they work really well
for kids that are emergent bilingual or
if you have English speakers go into the
one-way dual language programs, they
exit, they speak Spanish, they speak
English. If you're a
commented earlier today that she's that
she's gone. My worry is that that's
going to be the choice is we're not
going to have the space. We're going to
have to go to the neighborhood school
that has a one-way dual language program
and it's not the same as what we signed
on for
>> or no DL track at all. My second
concern, and this is a little bit um
sorry guys, I'm going to go fast. My
second concern is that you are
dismantling really good schools and
you're going to kind of fertilize the
rest of of other schools with kids that
have scored well to try to bring up an
average.
Does that make sense? Hear me out. Okay,
hear me out. Okay, so by doing by doing
that, there are kids that made schools
fail. And although whenever there's
going to be the dispersement of of of
other kids, the schools will eventually
increase, but you have kids that are
going to graduate in AI that are still
failing. And so I realize that there's
turnaround plans, but there are there
are thousands of kids that are going to
fall through the cracks, and I'm worried
about those kids. Okay, those that's it.
That's all I got.
Uh, so my my first response is um
aren't failing because of who they are,
the color of their skin, but but you
said kids, but you said kids fail. Like
there's kids that are failing. And I
want to just acknowledge that AISD like
so AISD AISD I just I just want to say
that the way that it was received was
maybe more like felt like that. So I
just want to acknowledge like the way
that I received it. So I I appreciate
you clarifying. I appreciate that. Um,
and I I I don't think that's kind of the
vibe. That's not I just wanted to just
>> I I know, but I just want to be really
really clear because sometimes that
happens where it is it is it is shared
as though if student movement occurs,
we're just dispersing students to all of
a sudden raise grades, which that was
but but okay. So, but what that that's
>> okay, but the problem that's not we're
not moving students to raise grades.
What we're trying to do is to identify
that they get what they need to be
academically successful. That's but it's
not student movement. It's not student
movement. It's us. It's us. Like it it's
it's the resources required to ensure
that every student gets what they need.
It's not moving students to all of a
sudden pass a test.
>> Can we um there there was a request from
the side of the room to um allow one
speaker to speak at a time and not to
interrupt. So we're addressing her
question at this point. Thank you.
>> Yeah. So it's it's we're not moving
students to raise grades. What we're
trying to do is to find resources to
ensure that all of our students get what
they need to be successful. It has
nothing the movement is a function of
what has to be done to actually pull out
and identify time.
We're not moving. Sorry. We're not
moving teacher. Uh
I mean that's I appreciate that's how
you feel. I understand that and I accept
that, but that's not what we're doing.
That's not the purpose of it. We
wouldn't have that would be a different
plan. In fact,
>> spoke earlier today.
>> Yeah. So when we had the meeting with uh
during the copy with the principal, it
was also something that was mentioned
that when you do disperse kids to
schools that are not academically
successful, it will lift up the overall
average. And it's not there wasn't a
like a them versus us versus Brown
versus that. That's not the money versus
that's not my intention. I'm actually
concerned about kids that I think are
going to fall through the cracks through
all of this that's going on through the
consolidation process.
>> I got you. Okay. Yeah. I mean, I just,
you know, we we don't have the f we're
we're an inch deep a mile wide. That's
just the honest truth. You know, if we
want educators to be able to stay and
have a chance of living in Austin, we
have to compensate. If we want to, you
know, look at different ways of
educating, you know, to save money, we
can do that. But we made decisions along
the way that costs us real resources.
You know, we have librarians.
That's not something that is like, you
know, covered by the state necessarily.
We have licensed nurses. We pay for our
own curriculum. We can save $8 million
if I wanted to adopt a curriculum, but I
can guarantee you just not a single
person in this room that want me to
adopt that curriculum. So, so we
protected planning time. You know, there
are things that we've done that have
cost us
just resources. And because we've said
this is how we elect to educate our
students, I now need to find those
resources to protect that educational
experience and at the same time be able
to ensure that every student gets what
they need. That that's that is where the
tension is in the system. So, um I know
it it's not a direct response to the
movement of the students because I I
just we would never would move students
just to raise grades. That's not what
we're trying to do here. But I can tell
you that we do not have the ability to
continue on and and really move in a way
that gets all of our students what they
need to be successful no matter where
they are. So we can continue to talk
about Oh, hey.
>> Hi. Hi. Um, my name is Staca Pascal. I
serve as the director of strategic
planning and organizational
effectiveness. And so I hear the heart
of your question, so I wanted to just
jump in. Um, one of the things that my
role does is think about as we're making
plans, how do the plans impact the
humans at the center of the design,
right? The humans in our students, our
staff, our entire organization.
And what we are seeing in this process
is that there are many unknowns which
then create a level of fear because of
the uncertainty.
And so if I'm hearing the the essence of
your question, it is thinking about
students being leveraged in the system
and not wanting that to be an outcome.
Is that right?
>> No, I'm worried about the kids that are
going to fall through the cracks. I'm
not worried about the kids being
leveraged. I'm worried about the kids
that are going to be moved around during
this consolidation process and that are
never going to catch up. Those are the
kids that I'm worried about.
>> Right. Exactly. So kids not having the
needs met. So, one thing I want to speak
to that's happening and it doesn't get
publicized throughout all of these
things is the work of the bridge team
and I'm a part of that team and our work
is really centered on how are we
supporting students now in this process
as they see all of us with our passion
for our students advocating and not
attaching that they think coming to my
school would be bad or they think my
school closing then that means they
don't want me to be here. So, we're
really focusing on how are we looking at
our morning meetings, how are we looking
at advisory lessons, how are we
supporting teachers so that our identity
isn't lost in this process. So, that's
one piece. Another piece that's
happening is professional learning with
our counselors as well as our principles
and how to lead and support during this
process. How are we identifying students
who may have had other things happen and
this becomes a trigger for them and they
need to have extra attention. So, are we
doing our one-on- ons or our seven
minute meetings? That's another part.
The other piece is we are working on our
transition plan for care for students.
Looking at not just like the academic
piece, but how are we attending to the
students so that they can actually show
up and learn, right? So, that is taking
place as well. We have research that
we're using. We're utilizing information
from other school districts that have
gone through this process as well. So
it's licensed mental health
professionals, our restorative practice,
we're using transformative seal, our
counselors as well. So that that part is
happening. It's just not something
that's embedded in the forefront. So I
just wanted to name that as well.
You also had a question well about space
and I didn't get a chance to talk a
little bit of that earlier so I wanted
to address it as well when we started
this process and you saw the data rubric
you saw a lot of numbers we were not
counting portables some people didn't
like that in the beginning but it did
offer us an opportunity to have
flexibility and so we do have portables
at ODM and JSLin that can be used during
this process I know when we originally
put out the draft plan there wasn't the
grandfathering, the continuation
transfer, the portables do allow us to
do that. And so while they're not in the
data rubric and those numbers, we have
them on some campuses to have that
flexibility. So I just wanted to talk
through that.
>> Thanks. Um John Powers, um one question
I have on the the plan, you talked about
like um you know the whole rubric. Um
I'm curious like there are other
instances in the United States of
consolidation like specifically Chicago
for example like 12 years ago. I'm can
you give me a specific example of how
you can take a lesson learned from a
community like that and how you applied
this plan differently to try to like get
a different outcome.
>> Yeah. So
couple u two things come to mind. So I
I've studied Chicago, San Antonio. I
mean there's been lots and lots of
school districts unfortunately that are
going through this. Chicago is the first
big one. Uh it was it was massive. Um
couple lessons learned I would say is uh
first and foremost the the plan uh the
data the process has to be tight. Um you
know I will tell you in my experience
and what I observed is that if there are
questions around the validity of the
data or how came about then there's
going to be questions around kind of the
outcome that you arrived at. I would say
two being really clear about what
informed the decision. So in 2019 when
we went through consolidations last time
there was a lot of input and then there
was a lot of collaboration and then
there was an output which was the list
of schools. uh in this instance we were
very clear this is the logic that we use
we may not all agree on the logic but
this is logic that was used to arrive at
that um recommendation in that initial
plan so that was number two I would say
the third thing this is what I
experienced here at Mets um and and uh
and Sanchez as well as Norman and Sims
and I also observe this uh um out in
Houston on some work they did was you
have to really spend the energy on the
limitation plan you know that that's
like the big thing like right now what
I'm really worried about is that somehow
we push and push and push the can down
the road and then all of a sudden we're
making a decision when there's very
little time for us to be able to support
your family and students. Y'all weren't
affected by this really, but just a
couple years ago in 2023, I've said this
before, we elected to move sixth grade
out of Mendes and Martin in April. We
elected to move international out of
East College High School in April. And
we were reeling from it that entire
semester through the summer. And all of
our sixth grade students who ended up at
the elementary schools the following
year never actually got what they needed
to be successful. We were scrambling
with instruments. Fine arts and PE are
very different in sixth grade than they
are in fifth grade. The certifications
are different. The staffing are
different. This way the building works.
All of that is different. And so I I am
wanting to make sure that we if we're
going to make a hard decision, you make
it with enough time to plan
thoughtfully. Uh so those would be the
three things that I have observed and
try to incorporate in this plan which is
why I'm really pushing for whatever
decision you know whatever thing we do
in any any year that it occur in
November because the registration
process for enrollment starts in
November. If I wait till January or any
time after that then I use half of that
time that creates a disruption in the
back end and then families get
frustrated because the system doesn't
work. But those are the sorts of things
that I'm really trying to to navigate as
we do this. Of course,
>> as the um leader uh of the enrollment
department among others, I would like to
clarify that typically our enroll
enrollment starts in November. Um please
do not panic that things are happening
tomorrow. We do have a revised timeline
for this year. Round one will open in
January and the precise dates we hope to
share um soon. Uh but yeah, thank you.
>> Do you mind? Hello.
>> Hello. Um, so I really respect that
you're trying to sol solve many problems
with one solution. You kind of listed
out your five problems that you're
trying to
coales and address, right? Kind of feel
like you're missing your bigger problem.
You're losing students to charter
schools because your schools are
underperforming. How is closing good
schools helping you retain students and
not losing more? How does it not
accelerate parents moving their kids to
charter schools? How does it not
accelerate losing local control of your
school district? It does address those
five problems in some fashion, but it
does not address that if you were trying
to retain students and have good
schools, you would not close good
schools. Yeah. So I would uh [applause]
the one thing I would say is um
there are school districts um who will
have you know different student
populations different demographics but
uh have
not our designation states designation
only higher performing schools right but
they still have the financial challenges
so they're they I understand how it can
feel as though if you only do this to
high performing schools
you know, then somehow it's not you're
not going to free up resources or that
it's not going to help the whole. But
there are consolidations happening in
central Texas in school districts that
have historically been high performing,
lots of wealth, lots of privilege, but
they're still closing because they're
they're they they are not um tied in the
way that a lot of people think. you're
you're right that if you close a higher
performing school, there is going to be
that feeling as though, you know, that
we're not um supporting what we think is
in the best interest of our kids. And my
my challenge and my the position on that
is there are lots of schools right now
the state has identified as not high
performing and those rooms are just as
full as this room. There are families
that love those schools and we'll do
anything to keep those schools open and
and they will tell you like MTS do
whatever you can to keep it open or keep
you know you know moving us in the right
direction but the reality is those
students have different needs and so in
order for me to have the resources to
provide those supports I need more more
more resources I need more funding I
need more like I I need to address the
inefficiencies in the system so um
you're Huh
So I I don't disagree that we need more
students, but this we live in a city
where there are less students. Just to
be honest, the the birth rate Yeah, we
have the data. The birth rate has I'm
sorry, that's not the total net the
total denominator has decreased. That's
the honest group. Our our our position
in the public education space in Austin
is in the Austin area hasn't really
shifted that much uh since maybe 15
years ago when like you saw the big kind
of influx of charter schools. We are all
losing. Charter schools are closing now,
too. I'm not sure if that's well known,
but there have been several in the
Austin area that closed recently. And
so, I just want to be really, really
clear. Um, we are desperately trying to
communicate that we as a school district
believe that we offer the best um the
best uh public education experience in
Austin, period. Secondly, I know that
every student has a different need and I
need to have the the ability to provide,
you know, resources to meet those needs.
Um, I want to get students back from
charters. I want to get students back
from home school, which is a new thing.
And we also know that bounces are
coming, right? They're going to be here
before you know it.
>> So, and our argument is if we actually
invest in the way that we should have
been for years past, then those schools
who are not good, right? I'm using your
words, not my words, and they increase
and we provide what we need for them,
then students will come back, right? I
mean because we know that families make
decisions based on the data they have.
But I I there are incredible things
happening in all of our schools. You
know, I just want to say a D school, an
F school, a C school, you know, there
are reasons that are not their the
students fault as to why we got there.
It's the district's fault. And so that
that's that's why we don't kind of lean
into that argument because I'm I'm
really trying to make sure that we
support the whole. It's the 70,000
students that have to get supported by
the decisions we make.
We're not moving.
>> I I wouldn't Yeah, I I don't agree with
fertilization, but
>> I understand that.
>> Hi.
>> Um I have more of a localized question
for this neighborhood in this area given
that you're closing two neighborhood
schools next to each other in Becker and
Dawson. Um and a lot of us are going to
be zoned to go to Galindo. So could
someone here please clarify what the
dual language situation at Glindo is?
Our understanding is that current
Gossson zoned and newly Glindo zone
families both in the Glindo area and
also the Becker zone which was proposed
to be moved to Glindo at the meeting
earlier this this week. Um we've been
given the impression that after meeting
with the folks at Dawson uh that there's
room for dual language at Galindo for
for families that are interested. Um but
in contacting that school directly, they
said they only have one way uh education
there. So please would you please
clarify if English speakers will be able
to learn Spanish at Gindo Elementary
School going forward?
>> Yeah, thank you so much for asking that
question. Um we have been planning for
that bigger piece, right? We heard from
the community they wanted to move
together. That's been a lot of our
focus. But your question is great
because Belindo does have a dual
language program. Our policy does allow
um that that is a wonderful thing when
we open up enroll Austin any family like
in the past if it if a school had been
designated as a oneway there wasn't a
mechanism for families to be able to
apply to those schools there are now um
and so during the enroll Austin period
you will see all of the schools listed
right that you can transfer into it will
become your new zone school and so zone
students will be able to participate in
the program that that school offers.
>> So given the challenge that has been
addressed at this meeting about
retaining and hiring qualified bilingual
teachers, can you guarantee that we will
be able to access that program at
Echendo?
>> So guarantee is a strong word, but right
after this, I'm going to go ahead and
and meet um with the principal. I'll
talk to the campus to make sure that we
have a clear understanding. The way
we're set up is with a zoned if you're
zoned to that school, you can
participate in the program in that
school because you're you're already an
existing dual language student.
>> Can you just clarify there that we
understood from speaking with the staff
there that it was a one-way program. Can
you just more directly and comment on
one way versus two-way at Galindo
specifically?
>> Okay. So, so I'm going to actually speak
a little more general just in terms of
because there we've got over 50 schools,
right? And some of them are what would
have been classified as a one-way and
some are two-way, but it's dual
language. Like we've been treating it as
dual language for a few years now. And
the reason for that was to make sure
that our families all across the city
could access maybe the the school that
was closest to them, right? So even if
you had already been zoned to Galindo in
the past, right, you still would have
been able to apply into that dual
language program to to get in. Um so so
those pieces are not changing. The main
difference and why people call, you
know, we say one way and two-way is just
because one way means that predominantly
there are students in that zone that
would potentially take up the majority
of the seats, right? because again it
speaks to the students that actually
live [clears throat] in the area and are
zoned to that area. So reside. So it one
way speaks to like the makeup of each
classroom. So some classrooms have a
makeup of every seat is an emergent
bilingual student in the classroom,
right? two-way campuses when they're
called that way just means that maybe
they do have emergent bilingual students
in that campus zoned area that reside
but there are still enough seats to be
able to welcome non-emergent bilingual
students. The makeup of that classroom
has a makeup of two groups of students,
emergent bilingual, non-emergent
bilingual. The um resources are the
same, the professional learning is the
same. So the model itself and the design
is the same. It's more the makeup of the
students that are in the classrooms.
>> Hi y'all. Um so I'm speaking as a
parent. Um I'm also a district employee,
so I just want to make sure
Sorry, I'm getting emotional. I really
wasn't trying to. Um, I need everybody
to know that the dehumanizing language
and extremely aggressive behavior
does not reflect everybody here and most
certainly [applause] does not reflect
the staff
that is at this campus.
Um Barrett, Jackie, Daniela, they're the
reason I bring my child here. [applause]
Um I'm parenting a child with a trauma
history. So I need y'all to understand
when you are referring to people who are
from other communities and robbing them
of their identities, you're talking
about my kid.
I'm really sorry, y'all.
And so I just want you all to know that
I appreciate greatly the care that has
been put into this plan
to make sure that every community is
getting taken care of. You know, we got
to see people coming in here going on
field trips. Not every kid in AISD gets
that. Not every kid knows that they're
going to go home to food. They're
experiencing poverty. And this district
cares for our kids. They take care of
them. The trauma informed care that is
embedded into this district is why I
bring my kids here and and the staff at
this campus is just amazing.
[applause]
I would love to
just encourage the district to
make sure that we are really taking care
to be mindful of kids of kids who are
experiencing trauma. Um I'm sorry I'm
like feeling sick. Um but I just thank
you
[applause]
I want to thank you for saying that and
I would love to walk out with you and
and if you know anything about the work
that we do in social emotional learning,
you know that that is at the center and
I so appreciate you saying that because
it's so important that as we're
advocating as parents, we have children
watching us, right? And I don't want any
child to walk away from this process
losing their identity in this battle
that we have happening between our
campuses. So I I thank you as a parent.
I thank you as a staff member. I thank
you as a human for sharing with us that
there are faces that go with these lived
experiences that our students have. So
uh thank you.
>> Hi. My name is Don Hogan. Um my I'm
named after my grandfather Donato
Rivera. Um his wife Luis Garcia um was
one of 13 um was the oldest of 13
children. I grew up visiting my
grandparents and hearing Spanish spoken
to their uh siblings and to my great
aunts and my great uncles. But growing
up it was normal because to me that I
was not a Spanish speaker because I just
knew that my grandparents just chose not
to teach their children Spanish.
It was just a normal fact of life. It
wasn't until visiting Becker that I was
given the vocabulary and hearing for the
first time the word language oppression
that it clicked and visiting as a you
know the kindergarten orientation of
like hey what are we going to visit
schools that I sobbing in the library uh
after hearing that and feeling the gift
that I get to give my children that I'm
unable to give myself that is the um
what language immersion brings to their
their education
That is the importance that I come as a
non-emergent
individual.
And so my question, my request is, can
we make a change to enroll Austin as a
way to kind of highlight
individuals like me and families like me
and myself that feel invisible in this
process and be able to measure
the population of heritage Hispanic
families that see public education as a
way to give that gift back to their
family and to close and heal the wounds
that have been generational.
And that way
[applause]
and that way be beginning to measure
a population that doesn't exist then I
think gives AISD
the leadership in the state to step
forward and be
lead in advance of what the TEA
regulation is in terms of having a 50-50
population for these intents and
understand that there's
more of the nuance than just having only
two options, but as a way to continue to
use the tools that is AISD and public
education to heal past wounds of
language oppression.
So, uh, [applause]
so that comment gives me chills and and
my experience is very similar to you. I
grew up in Austin. My parents spoke
Spanish. I I Spanish I I I knew well,
but I wasn't fluent. I all through
elementary school, middle school, and
high school by math. If you run into
people at a bar that knew me in high
school, they'll say, "Oh, you know,
Matt." Um, and and I kind of gave up who
I was. I'm Matias Cigar the Third. Um,
but I just went by Matt and um, you
know, so my daughters went to Sunset
Valley. You know, most people don't know
that they went to Sunset Valley to do
exactly what what you all are doing
here. And I I am I am part of that
community and understand how valuable it
is. I talk about students success and I
see being bilingual as a superpower and
I believe it the and so I just want you
to know that I recognize that that is an
opportunity of growth for us right now.
We haven't been able to work on the
important stuff because we've been so
hammered with the urgent. That's just
the honest truth. Like the the TA greed
order, the budget, the changes from the
legislative, you know, sessions, the the
accountability. But I'm desperately
trying to get us out of these periods of
disruption so that we can grow and
thrive and then make decisions that
impact all of our kids kind of and our
families kind of in the way that you're
suggesting because that's where I want
to go. That's where we collectively want
to go. It's just there's only so much we
can tackle at any given point and we
have to get through these moments. So
that's thank you for saying that. I very
much appreciate it. Um and that's kind
of one of the things that we're trying
to do as we move forward honestly. Thank
you.
[applause]
>> Hi, I am not a I don't feel like a
strong public speaker. Um I am a parent
of a current fourth grader and a also a
Becker graduate who is in dual language
program at Lively and also in the magnet
there. Um and I have stood in this line
for a long time so I'm going to ask
quick but more than one. Um I'm going to
ask I watched the working board meeting.
Um I'm going to ask about Jocelyn
language immersion but receiving
transportation for all students. Why is
Sanchez or the other dual language
campuses not receiving transportation
for all students?
Um I am also going to ask about the
transfer policy that was proposed that
any current transfer at any school can
go to the new zone school for
um the resides population that was
mentioned at that meeting that was said
was coming out in the um new plan. And
if that applies to dual language
campuses, can all 500 of our community
members go to Zilker or go to Belindo?
Obviously that is not possible, but that
is what you said at the board meeting
was possible. Um and then
uh one more well two more sorry. Um the
when we brought up the historic nature
of this campus, I also went to Zilker
Elementary. So I'm a South Austin local.
Students walked from Becker to found
Zilker. Right. This was the first
neighborhood school in South Austin that
has been considered for Zabala
Elementary, which was built the exact
same year. Why has that not been
considered for South Austin? Why? Sorry.
Why in that meeting did you spend 45
minutes explaining that you wanted to
keep schools open in East Austin, which
I support,
and that a 200
resides population school, two 200
resides population schools should stay
open because they were historic. But
Becker, that doesn't matter.
Why
um were you talking about putting
Monasuri in that area of town so that
you could keep the schools which again I
support. Why is that not considered when
you are adversely affecting one
neighborhood with Dawson
and Becker both closing within a mile of
each other. So we are hearing you. We
are here. We I think as a community, we
agree with the guiding principles of the
plan. And at every turn, you are saying,
"Oh, except for Becker. You can cross a
highway. You can cross a river. You you
can have your neighborhood unreasonably
impacted by closing two schools that are
right next to each other. Your historic
school won't be given a pass for only
having 175 reside students which is very
close to 200 or less which is projected
at Savala because because why? And then
I have a actual specific question that I
would really like to ask
>> but you can answer these first and then
I will
>> that's a four-part question. I some of
them are very different so I'm trying to
I want to make sure I I
>> and you might not be able to answer them
all now. I wanted them to be said out
loud and considered.
>> Yeah. Um I appreciate that. Uh so on the
transfers, we we have that clarity. I
will we will make sure that gets
communicated out. Um I can spend time on
it now, but I we're making adjustments
and refining. Uh you heard us talk about
why we leave their space and kind of
what we've seen historically. So yes,
we're still committed that if there are
students that want to continue on as
much as they'll have that ability. Um
the the question around um uh historical
buildings, I'm assuming you're talking
about Black Sherry. My assumption.
>> Yeah. I was just you talked about Zabalo
which is a parallel school to Becker.
>> Yeah. And so and and so the plan
actually considers and again this may
change um based on all the conversations
from trustees and everything else. Um
but in the revised plan we're sending
more students to Zavala because Go
Valley would ultimately you know if the
plan stayed convert into a monastery
because there there are too many seats
in that area right so the monastery
program doesn't go there then we would
have to close a school whether it's any
one of those schools it it's it's just a
school that would have to close um the
fact that we have built a new school uh
for go valley is something that we're
talking about now for black oak springs
is going into black so in that way we're
actuallying adding more students. So, in
both cases, we're we're adding students.
Um it wasn't they got a pass, it's just
that when you look at the area kind of
given the available spaces where our
students are, we just don't have that
many options. Um so, I hear you on this
in this specific area. Uh when it comes
to, you know, highways and rivers, you
know, given the complexity of the
system, not every every I hear it both
ways, you know, it's in every boundary
change. Um we are looking at them. We
are taking feedback and we can make
adjustments. We are uh the Joslyn I was
>> oh that there it said that they would
get transportation for all students to
join and to go valley um and join as the
immersion
um is immersion to language also why
can't we be an immersion to language?
>> Uh so that's a different question.
>> You don't have to answer that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's a different question.
Probably a longer conversation. Um, so
the monastery program already has
districtwide transportation. So, so
that's it's not a change. Um, now, uh,
for Joslyn, that's one of the things
that's come up. Uh, it's it's been
talked about. Um, you know, plan will
still evolve. We are looking at that. We
understand the effect that has. When it
comes to, uh, the four wallto- walls, we
are adding capacity. So, as a district,
we want to add seats in the wall to
wallage program. There's 650 seats being
an added net between the fours. uh which
I think is going to help our overall
like kind of support of wallto- wall
dual language. And then what we said is
we're going to add transportation to
ensure that the emerging bilingual
students who may not feel like they have
access to the school keep access. So
we're not going to necessarily expand
the attendance boundary beyond the
current attendance boundary. What we're
saying is you're already coming here.
This is your home. We want you to see
yourself in this school. Let's go ahead
and continue the transition routes that
we already have in place. kind of a
budget control item. But again, some of
that may change, but I just want to
share with you thought process.
>> Yeah, I think that that thought process
makes a lot of sense. You're also
telling Becker that our students should
see Sanchez as our home school and we're
more than three miles away across from a
highway. And so even if we are not
emergent bilingual students at least
during transition it feels reasonable to
offer transportation to our campus or
and other I mean that's that's all I
just want to say that you don't have to
we that's we've heard that um I think
the challenge we've heard that we are
kind of looking at all of the
transportation routes how we provide
support during periods of transition.
You know what I I don't want to
communicate is that we'll be able to
kind of things on in perpetuity. But I
also want to acknowledge that for this
period of time as we transition students
and as communities come together, we
build new school communities, we have to
make accommodations and I have that I
mean I just you know it's just there's
lot there are lots of families that are
spread out all over the city. Um so I
just have to think through kind of what
could be considered. We are looking at
>> sorry everybody this was just my last
one because it was it hasn't been
addressed. Um my daughter and my son and
myself before them go to Darity Arts
after school care. I was I went there as
a child. They go there as a child. Right
now we have van transportation from
Becker that they ride that they take a
van free and Zilker has a school bus
that is provided by the district. This
is an important afterchool program and
resource for our community. It's not
just my children, right? there's many
other children and so the continuity of
having that and also I will say creative
action probably for the people who go to
that at this school um at the next
campus I consideration for a bus from
AISD for the new zoned dual language and
so Sanchez or Gindo or Zilker Zilker
already has a bus right they've already
been provided that for arts so that we
could have some continuity children I
just ask that that be considered
Yeah. So, um, thank you for that. Those
are the types of things, you know, as we
move through the process, we are going
to be very intentional about developing
these transition plans. Those sorts of
things that we can adjust, you know, as
leadership comes together as we plan.
Um, that that that's the type of
feedback that we need. Now, again, we
want to get the principles in place. We
want to begin to move through it, but
that's exactly what we have the ability
to do. Um, so and then on the
transportation for Zilker, I'm not sure
if it's an AISD expense or it's actually
uh something that is raised locally and
then paid for. So I just need to
understand that before I can commit to
anything. But I suspect based on what I
heard it's probably locally raised and
then they pay transportation. It's not
us kind of paying on their behalf for
that program. But we can we have that
flexibility.
>> All right. Um so let me first say like I
understand the the incredibly difficult
situation. Um you the superintendent and
the board has been put in like this by
the state right I I I understand that um
and you know I know the motivation for
the consolidation plan was uh budgetary
right like like budget sorts but my my
concern is really
long term for AISD right the the rates
of attrition like I it's been it's been
dropping off
um it's been dropping off um in and I'm
concerned that this plan is going to
have a much higher rate of attrition. Um
I haven't seen any modeling for that in
anywhere. I know there's modeling data
based on previous school consolidation
plans um you know in other areas. Um
that just um I I haven't seen it
anywhere in this plan and you know just
for for this community right here um I I
know there's surveys that gone out
there's like 30% of families considering
uh alternatives to AISD schools. um you
know uh and you know a lot of that's
motivated by by uh anxiety a lot of this
is motivated by the plan so so can you
speak to um you know projected retrition
rates um for AISD and how you guys are
going to win back trust in families here
um after this plan is is is put in place
or whatever happens um you know or post
decisions.
So,
I I want to acknowledge that there's
going to be a disruption and I always
want families to do what's best for
their students like period. Um I I also
want to acknowledge that, you know, we
are trying to desperately get on the
other end of this where families are
welcomed or have see themselves in our
schools, which isn't happen necessarily
at many of our schools because we see
the transfer out rates, right? they're
choosing to leave either that school or
go to a charter school or to go to
wherever they would like. And um
regarding a plan as far as uh you know
what we expect to occur, um I've looked
at what has happened here in 2019. Um
unfortunately what happened in 2019 is
we went through a consolidation process
and then three months later the pandemic
happened. So there was so much student
movement that it kind of overwhelmed any
kind of understanding of what was
happening locally if that makes any
sense because I mean we had students
just completely unenrolled because of
the masks that we were requiring you
know in our schools. We had lots of that
happen so I can't look at that as a
reasonable data point to apply here. I
look at other school districts. San
Antonio went through it. Richardson went
through it. They saw a slight decrease
as a district. Um, now when it comes to
campus by campus, it could increase.
What I also worry about is I've gotten
um I've had experiences in the past just
I'm I say this because it's a it's a
lived experience that I had with the
community and it was a letter saying 80%
are going to to leave and then we go
through the process, we work together,
we build it together and the number is
very different. Um, so I I I believe,
you know, for modeling purposes, you
know, I would say 15 to 25% kind of in
the short term is probably a a higher
number. It'll settle in and then after
18 months, it'll kind of tend to come
back. And then also, you know, what does
that look like? We know lots of families
anchor themselves into the high school
like kind of um experience that we have
in Austin IC, which we love. We're so
excited. We have incredible high schools
and so there are shifts, but then we
often see families come back. So we are
modeling it. Our budget has asked our
trustees have asked me for it. I'm doing
a sensitivity analysis around if we lose
5% 10% of that localized student
population, if we lose elsewhere in the
district, what does that look like? But
I also want to communicate that there
are lots of families who I think um
based on some of these changes are
actually going to come back into Austin
ISD and we have heard that as well. So I
just that is what makes it complex. we
are making those um sensitivity analysis
available to our trustees but that's why
I can't tell you for certain oh you know
we're going to lose 10% 5% for that
we're going to grow um but we are
showing that analysis okay and then so
uh a follow-up question specifically for
the parents here right because I know
you guys probably all feeling the same
anxiety that we are right like as
pointed out I think Joe pointed out
earlier like the um u the numbers just
don't add up like the amount of dual
language seats that are available um
for Becker students like going you know
like there's a there's a shortfall in
seats I think it's like 10% of of dual
language kids like right now that that's
a very opaque um uh process right now we
don't really understand uh how it's
going to shake out timelines things like
that like we have to make plans for our
kids for for next year you know if if
Becker if Becker closes you know I I
hope it doesn't but um if we we have to
plan like what does that look like um
you you know, like can you can you give
us some guarantees on deadlines and
things like that so we can make plans?
>> Yeah. So, um I I am very close to all
this work. Um the transition plans are a
big part of this. Uh regarding
milestones of everything from the
principal being hired, when we're going
to communicate transportation, uh it
sounds like what you want before any of
that is assurances based on kind of the
flexibility we know that each campus has
that the campus that we're saying will
welcome your students can indeed fit
your students. Right. It sounds like a
originally released was because we're
using permanent capacity as the kind of
underlying denominator. It um feels as
though when you go through the
calculation that you're going to exceed
100% utilization, right? That's the
that's the main root of it.
>> So, so again, there are things that we
observe in student movement. The 100%
assumption is um not one that we often
see. I'm just going to say that because
families just choose to do different
things year-over-year. Secondly, you
know, portables are meant to be
short-term solutions. We as a district
leaned into them and made them
permanent. some of the most expensive
spaces we have in Austin ice. We have
over 500, no 480 portables like at this
moment representing about 800,000 square
feet are effectively two buoy high
schools. And so um we over time need to
shed ourselves of that very expensive
space, but in shortterm kind of relief
situations, they can be used. You use
them here, they're used all throughout
the district. And that is part of what
gives that flexibility at those schools
because they exist right now. Now over
time, once this stabilizes, they need to
go. And you know, we we our newest
portable is 30 years old. You know, that
that's just so I what we need to do and
I'm going to commit to doing that is be
hyper precise on how the numbers work
for these communities that are making
that transition and what we're relying
on to share and understand that yes,
they the student the families and
students fit even with transfers. That's
why we've been able comfortable enough
to say with transfers. Um but you
haven't been able to see that because of
how we're using the space and the
walkthroughs that the staff is doing.
They're walking through each campus and
saying, "Hey, this is how it works. It
we can make it work. This is our path
forward." That's what we owe you. That's
what we owe the communities. Um, and we
can get that out before the vote because
we we've been working through it. We
have
>> Please do because you guys are are at
risk of losing a lot of families.
>> I appreciate that comment. That's a
that's a good that's something.
I've been thinking about this a lot
because I've been hearing this
attrition, this go-to charter, this goto
private as an option as these changes
happen. Um, and I I don't like it
because these campuses, these
communities are successful also because
of you. And this plan, however it moves
forward in whatever shape, will have a
higher success rate if we continue to
have your support.
That is critical. We need your continued
support. So, as you're weighing your
options, leaving public education only
makes this more difficult.
[applause]
>> Good morning, everyone. I'm Wendy Mills.
I used to be the principal of both
Norman and Sims. And then when we
consolidated, I was the principal of
Norman Sims. And I remember being in
this very position at community meetings
where I had Norman parents sitting on
one side, Sims parents sitting on the
other, we were8 miles down the road from
each other. And there were folks yelling
at me every day, we are not going, if
you move us point8 miles up the road, no
river, no nothing. We are not going to
go, Miss Mills. And I had to just sit
there in that and say exactly what
Travis says. If that is your choice,
that's your choice. But I would hope
that you would stick with us and play
the long game. I know it's hard. Any
change is hard. And just see the access
and opportunity that will come for both
of our communities if we stick together.
Those same uh parents five years later
when I announced that I was leaving the
school were in tears saying we gave you
the business mills. They were like we
were so ugly. We were just like losing
it. And now to look at where we are and
what our school has become. They they
just were like apologizing. I didn't
need an apology because I understood
these are their kids. Change is hard.
But they said if we could have seen five
years down the line what we have now
versus where we were sitting in these
seats at six o'clock 7 o'clock many
nights holding our posters rallying
going down to the old HQ headquarters
building on East Six Street just yelling
and screaming and kicking and fighting
only to realize that at the end of all
of this it was sweet. I mean newer
facility we had a building Sims was very
much like this. I mean, every time we
tried to plan a graduation, an event for
our parents, we were just so overcrowded
and overrun. And when they got there and
the doors open, I still have a video of
my teachers and families in the got to
go into that new building the next the
first time. I think it kind of hit that
this was the access and opportunity they
were trying to provide for both of those
communities. Was it hard? Absolutely.
But I do just want to say thank you
Travis for saying that because I had to
be bold enough to just I don't want to
say beg, but just plead to hang in there
with your community. Um it it gets
better with y'all through y'all. So
that's just my encouragement. I've been
there and uh I will continue to be here
to support in this time.
[applause]
>> No, that's what I'm saying. I said even
with that even with only8 miles there
was just this real resistance to the
change. So we understand
the bigger the bigger question I'm
saying the bigger comment I'm saying is
just I just appreciate him saying let's
just try to preserve the communities
that we have to stay in
here.
>> I I don't think that's not Travis and I
don't work that way. That's not how we
work.
I don't I don't that's not how he work.
He He would be employed if I wasn't here
either. I mean, so let's be clear.
>> It's that's not how
>> um Is that what you're about to say?
>> 10 minutes and these friends have been
very patient. My role is equity of
voice. So I get to be that person to
remind us about that. So I want you to
have their space.
>> So I have I have a couple of fears and I
have another statement and then I want
to ask a friend of mine if I didn't
bring my readers to read it read
something from another thing. So my big
fears is I have an asthmatic kid. We're
moving. It's right next to a highway. I
have a professional painter in my life
and you're really not supposed to.
[applause] Um so I I have a fear for the
kids that are there right now. I fear
for their help, you know, in the future.
Um I also have been part of community
the you know AISD I am a community
advocate and on the key side and I've
been part of some of these conversations
and from what I've taken back at the
after the fact conversations sometimes I
felt like they was put off from having
us there and they were just having as
part of the conversation just to have
the conversation and then they wanted to
get done as soon as possible. possible
about hearing community feedback. And
that's just how I felt with it. I love
it here. I love principal. I love our
teachers. I hope you're able to retain
all the teachers. Um even though some of
them don't know what you know people are
in their staff, you know, they don't
know what their future holds from.
Another concern of mine is you said your
report and implementing plans. This
feels like a rush plan and I have a fear
that this implementation
will not be done well and uh and this is
all these years are just you know just
are very important for all of our
growing minds all of our growing
friends. Um that being said I just
wanted to say some of my experience I
want to ask my friend Joe please he
could read something for me have my
readers on me getting older.
>> Yeah. Uh, the student population Becker
I'm reading this but if it says anything
crazy it's not on
>> the student population of Becker and
Sanchez are different. How will the
district ensure the dual language
program continues to equitably serve the
students who speak Spanish at home while
also integrating a high number of
English dominant students? uh what
ongoing support will be provided to
retain SA Sanchez teachers uh to teach
larger groups of English dominant
students in the dual language program.
Uh in this transition uh there's a
strong and valid focus on honoring and
protecting the Sanchez community. At the
same time, Becker is closing and there
are teachers and staff with more than a
decade of service, deep relationships
with students and families, uh and
meaningful school identities. What
concrete steps will the district take to
ensure that Becker teachers and staff
joining Sanchez are equally respected,
valued, and supported, preventing any of
us versus them dynamic uh and building a
single unified community from the start?
>> Yes. So,
>> yeah. So, I I want to Oh, I'm
>> I want to We're running now.
>> We heard it.
Perfect. Good morning. Thank you guys so
much for staying late. That's awesome of
all of you. Um, Greg H. So, Becker is an
awesome school. It's diverse. It's
that's proven through all the transfers
that come here. There's a smaller
percentage of zone students that also go
to Becker. So, what I would like to do
now is actually take off the dual
language hat and put on my hats, which
is a zoned student to Becker. Um, in a
lot of the in a lot of the the examples
and the solutions that have come up, we
hope that Becker stays. But in the event
that we can't find a solution that
Becker stays, the closest school to the
Becker zoned community is Zilker. It's
the school where we share playgrounds
with the other kids. It's the school
that is closest enough for us to bike
to, to walk to. Galindo is much, much
further away. And I start getting really
nervous that in the noise and in the
dual language conversation, we miss the
second part of your plan, which is very,
very good, which is let's create good
local schools for our kids and for our
neighborhoods, which is very important
to the people that live here. So, I'm
sorry that Dr. French isn't here to hear
that. If you guys could scribe that and
pass it on, that would be awesome. Thank
So, so, um, that is a big area of focus
for us. Um, uh, you I I just want you to
know we're on top of that. We understand
it. We
We're fine. I I hear you. I see.
>> Hi everyone. I'm Andrea. I have a second
year old daughter here at Becker and
this is our second year here. So, we're
still relatively new to the AISD.
Given AISD's ongoing budget deficit and
these proposed school consolidation
plans which the district has also said
that's intended to you know one of the
goals is to improve the state testing
performance. What concrete safeguards
are in place to ensure that we remain we
being AISD remains locally governed and
is not at risk at state intervention. if
these consolidations neither close the
best the deficit gap nor raise the test
scores as expected or desired because
it's like there's just so much
uncertainty and I can pretty much
guarantee that nobody wants their child
to be part of any financial or political
pawn situation and it's kind of feeling
that we could go down that road.
>> Yeah. So, um,
since the moment I came into this role,
January 9th, 2023,
uh, I've been dealing with existential
risks. Uh, I don't know if anybody
remembers, but the TA read order of
special education was a thing that was
going to take us down. Remember that?
That that wasn't that long ago. The T we
had a a a report from the agency. We had
for years past not, you know, been in
compliance. There there were lots of
things that had to change. And that was
a real risk. That risk was was almost as
great as the accountability risk if not
greater than we have now because didn't
have the luxury now that we have the
luxury of time but it was urgent. It was
happening. The report was already done.
There was a recommendation on the table
to move towards conservative. And so I
will tell you that the board and I are
very much uh aware of all the different
risks that we manage when it comes to
maintaining local control. I am hyper
thoughtful in every movie that we make.
And what I'll tell you is I strongly
believe that the elements of this plan
that move us further to retaining local
control um are are there in a in a
really significant way. And so when you
look at, you know, how we're um taking
three unacceptable rating schools and
supporting them or making adjustments
and reassignment or doing a restart, uh
we we feel confident, we have the data,
our teams are mobilized that we'll break
those accountability chains. And here's
the thing, we've been working so hard
over the last two years, multi-ter
system support, the curriculum that we
have, the fact that we have educators in
our classrooms now that we didn't have
three years ago, right? The investment
we made in instructional coaches by the
way of the tax re-election of 2024, the
fact that we've made compensation
increases in 23, 24, 20, 23, 24, 24, 25,
uh, has moved us significantly in the
right direction. Early literacy numbers
are through the roof. Early numeracy are
through the roof. Like we are moving the
system. You had I don't want to like
kind of get into this but you know we're
we had 30 Fs and 23 29 and 24 you have
23 and 25 and it is going to continue to
nose dive but it's because we're doing
it the right way. Like that's the thing
like there are different ways that you
can do that. We chose to take the long
sustainable route to where if anyone us
any one of us of us leaves it will still
be like embedded in our bones. Like
that's what we're trying to do. It's not
about passing tests. It's about loving
to learn how to like read like it's love
the love of reading. Um so that's who we
are. Uh I feel confident that this
manages the appropriate level of risk
but I have to execute that. That's
really the the the the thing that is
most important and I would hope that the
community sees what we've been able to
do around special education. That was a
huge risk over the last two years that
we've been managing day in and day out.
Our staff, our principles, the entire
system aligned to address that and we
are on the way end back end of that. Um,
so anyway, I just wanted to share that
with you. Um, I I feel confident this
moves us in the right direction, but
again, nothing is is for certain,
especially in the political realm that
we live in. Um, but we are thinking
about that continuously at every turn.
>> I'll try to be brief. I have one ask and
a couple of questions. Um, I did not
grow up in the States or AISD or
anything. The first time that I went to
the website was when my daughter was
like three years old and I tried to
understand what to do to give my
daughter the gift of Spanish. um and to
just make sure that she went to a place
where Spanish was valued. So I
understood that I had to transfer from
my son's school which is uh Pleasant
Hill. I understand that I had two
choices and I tried to make my life easy
and my first choice was Manaka because
it was very close to my clinic where I
work and the second was Becker even
though in my heart I wanted to go to
Becker first but because I like to make
my life easy I put Manaka number one. On
the day of the transfer, Manaka didn't
open up for us and Becker did and that
was a blessing because we had a lot of
friends coming here already and in the
bottom of my heart I wanted to come
here. So I want to say uh my ask is that
whatever we do and wherever we go we uh
make sure that the dual language is
respected and and is
supported um because we came here hoping
that her Spanish improved when she was
born. Everybody in the house spoke
Spanish to her. My husband first
language is English. And then a
linguistic friend of ours that sat
linguist said that's wrong. She's going
to picked up the bad phonetics from your
husband's Spanish. So she should speak
everybody should speak to her in their
native uh tongue. So then we switch. But
then but then she didn't speak Spanish.
She didn't want to speak Spanish even
though she understood everything. Then
we come to Becker for um kinder and all
of a sudden she starts speaking more
Spanish and she's in love with the
language and she respects the language
and she has pride pride for the language
and I don't think any curriculum or any
building can give kids that and I have a
fear because I've heard a rumor that the
state wants to do away with dual
language and Spanish in schools in
general and that makes me very fearful
and my ask for you guys is to just fight
for Spanish as much as you can so we
continue to give our kids this gift so
they are proficient in whatever they go
in life they can be proud of. Um she she
she could have spoke Spanish maybe but
um but the love and respect that now she
shows for Spanish I think is because of
the people in this school. It's nothing
about this particular building is
because of everybody here. So, one, if
we can continue that legacy, that would
be great. And two, if we can transplant
everybody here or at least support
everybody here that wants to go to the
next school that we go to, that would be
great. That's the ask. Um, and the
question is, um, say we go to Sanchez as
an elementary non-zone school, we will
be zoned because where we live that, uh,
to a middle school that doesn't have,
um, Spanish or strong solid program for
Spanish. what are the plans of the
district and uh where do I go from here?
What happens when she finishes
elementary and we go to a middle school
uh for a good Spanish program? How do we
go about that?
>> Yeah. So that's um that's where back to
alignment matters, right? Because
because there are experiences right now
where it does terminate your house.
>> No, absolutely. So, we uh you're not
going to see it come out in the plan
right now, but we are having
conversations behind the scenes about
what do feeders look like um for so we
do know we've got 13 middle schools
right now. It's not every single middle
school that offers dual language. We
know the ones in the area that do,
right? So, Lively does and Badas does.
So, we're we're still having those
conversations about are we going to
create feeders for the nonzone? Like,
what does that look like? Um but I don't
have an answer for you yet. It's on our
mind though.
>> Okay. And what support and what
resources will Sanchez if we'll decide
to go there will have for the Spanish
dual language?
>> Yes. So great thing is is that Sanchez
has a robust language program already.
Right. So they're resourced um as well.
Um what part of the transition plan will
be if this vote if there's a yes vote
for this plan for any of the of the plan
or pieces there'll be a transition. Um,
we heard Staca talk about the bridge.
It's going to be the bringing of the two
communities together and the planning
that includes the staff as well, right?
So, making sure that the staff have the
opportunity to work with each other and
get to know each other.
>> That's in term of social but resources
as in money. Do we have money to support
that staff for Sanchez?
>> So, they are currently
you have the budget.
>> Yes.
Hi.
>> Hi.
>> I'm going to probably be a little all
over the place, but I'll try to make
this quick. Thank you for being here.
Thank you for giving us this opportunity
to talk to you about this. My parents
moved to the United States when I was 2
years old. They went against the norm at
the time that I moved here and they
taught us Spanish. They taught my
brother and me Spanish at home and
forced us to speak it even though we
would sneak English whenever we could.
Uh that is a gift that I have done a
terrible job of giving my kids at home.
And that is why we chose Becker. We
chose Becker because it is a place from
the moment you arrive. You see Mr.
Barrett and Miss Martinez and all the
staff welcoming the kids, opening the
doors and saying buenosmen.
And I chose that over our zone school
which has a dual language program
because I wanted the wall-to-wall
experience. I want that for all kids
that want that experience. We're not
asking for anything like we want what
you want here, which is that all kids
that want that to have that experience.
We believe, we agree with what you just
said, Mr. Barrett, that Principal
Barrett, that we are stronger together
as a community. And we've heard today
that, and we heard early on in this
process that
we heard early on in this process that
your intention was to keep communities
together, but today we also heard that
you're kind of relying on people going
all over the place. And we want to stay
together and keep advocating. And we
want to help you be we want to help be
part of the solution to get you to the
goals that you have for AISD. We've
shown through this process. I've become
an activist. I've never been an
activist. I've been an activist for my
school dur for our school during this
process. But I will use that same energy
to keep fighting for what we want for
all kids.
And so I just as I heard you say that
you will be looking at some of the
proposals to keep a South Central option
so that our families can all stay
together. We appreciate that. I wish Dr.
French were still here so that she could
pull up her maps and show it real time.
Uh but thank you for considering that. I
I um I hope that you can consider
keeping an option open that will allow
our families to stay together. And uh I
just also want to say, this is a total
other thought, but I just want to say it
that I heard you this week saying that
you're adding a sensitivity analysis to
your uh plan. And I think I heard you
say 1, three, and 5%. I'm concerned that
those percentages are too low for what
we've seen. I know you said you've
studied Chicago, San Antonio, and San
Antonio saw 20%. Uh I from my day job,
not as an activist, I know that it's a
lot harder. It costs a lot more to win
back students than it is to keep
students here and um and to use the
families like us that can that have the
resources and it can help recruit to
keep families here and to help you do
what you want to do which is to have
thriving schools for for all kids. So,
uh I think that's all just let us be
part of the solution with you instead of
how it's been so far.
>> [applause]
>> Thank you so much for all the work y'all
have done. I know it's really hard and
you can't make everyone happy. My
question is if the trustees vote no to
your plan, do you guys have a backup
plan to address the tips and the taps
and the pressure that you're having from
TEA to turn around these schools or is
it only this plan baked in this closure
consolidation?
>> Yeah. So um you in the work session we
talked about um there this plan is
inclusive of the taps right the taps are
legally required. Um I don't think that
uh we are in a position the board is in
a position to to not take a vote on
those elements of the plan. I will say
that there are other things that are
perceived as not being tied to taps that
are kind of tied to the plan and kind
of, you know, allow the tap to work in a
different way than it would otherwise. I
don't know if that was clear, but but
there's kind of some movements that have
to occur for some of these to not be um
to ensure success or to at least, you
know, improve success or probability of
success. Um so the backup plan, well,
there it can only be a board vote. uh
the board is the only entity that can
approve the tax. Uh you know, you're
asking about I think specifically a
breakup of the vote, right? That's kind
of like probably
>> Yeah.
So, so the option for the task seems to
be what's best for kids for those
specific schools based on the kind of
level of unaccountability risk that
we're managing, right? If that makes any
sense because there are some schools
that were 44, three years ago, they're,
you know, 52 and now they're 59. I mean,
they're they're like right there and the
growth is there. We see it and they're
going to get that pause and they're
going to go on and continue and break
the accountability chain. And there are
other schools that have a an F, but it's
a different kind of understanding of
what that means for that campus. And so
we're making those changes as well. Um,
we had to the November timeline for me
is important only because of the cycle
that we see ourselves in as a public
school system. I know that we've made
accommodations or adjustments already
for registration, but the reality of it
all is that we have to hire staff early
in the process so that our leaders can
hire their staff and then we can build a
program and we can work and figure out
how to get PTAs together and CAC's
together and then we have to have the
plans baked and ready to go so that when
summer breaks we're moving um teachers
to their new home. So, it's one of these
things where a delay is not two or three
months, it's click a year unless I'm
introduce a significant disruption in
the kind of learning experience of of
our system. Uh that's something in the
past we didn't learn from. Like I'm not
going to do that. I'm not going to make
a significant change in the spring
semester because we are already kneede
in planning for the following year. So,
>> uh regarding timelines, that's the board
regarding the vote. Um we're having
those conversations on like what is
legally required.
what what has to happen versus you know
what elements are tied to it which is
which ones are totally separate um I
wanted to make sure we considered all of
it because each one thing if it was
isolated would look very different if it
was all together but that conversation
is right now so they'll be thems
So,
>> no, that's I think that's
that's
[applause]
>> you you hit the nail on the head. That's
exactly um I mean I I appreciate you
laughing at that but that's that's
that's exactly right that but but that's
but that's but we can we we've
demonstrated the last two and a half
years that we can do very very difficult
things. Um I know that it doesn't maybe
um it's not always visible but there
have been countless hours and multiple
efforts to get to this point. We are not
flatfooted. We are very prepared and
well positioned to move forward. Yes,
there are other things that we have to
manage. everything adds risk or takes
risk away. So if as it gets pulled away,
if that were the case, then I would
argue that there's probably more risk on
the back end of it. Um the risk of delay
is pretty significant as a whole. Um
could you make adjustments? Could a
couple things move? Yes. But I would say
the kind of critical mass of what the
plan is really needs to be kept intact
if you're really going to mitigate risk
downstream. If not, you're going to wait
a year and then who knows what happens
that year. I know what will happen is
the deficit will continue to grow.
Miss Wilson, we need to go ahead and cut
this off. I know they have someplace to
be, but not only that, uh, we have staff
that need to get back into this space
and kids coming very soon. I would love
it if you would grab a couple chairs and
lean them against the wall out out back.
We'll stack them into the shipping
container later, but thank you so much.
I appreciate it.